make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so continuing our spider-man week
coverage we pick up with the ultimate
spider-man and the origin of miles
morales is the best way to say it miles
morales appeared before this particular
origin
but uh he was really just kind of like a
kid who was there and that was really
about it and this is interesting because
this brings in
really to like spider-man homecoming the
idea of miles more out this video is
being made two weeks before spider-man
homecoming so i have no idea
what goes on in that movie but i would
surmise
that miles morales will probably appear
in the movie but either he'll be a
post-credits scene or he'll just be a
kid who's mentioned
and that'll be about it and the reason
why that works is because of the fact
that that's what happened in the
ultimate universe this whole origin came
after miles morales first appeared prior
to this he was just a kid who was there
and that was really it there was no
expectation that he was going to grow
into anything
or become anything significant it was
kind of interesting because
to me there are a lot of aspects of
spider-man homecoming that pull directly
from the ultimate universe and it's
always been that way with the marvel
cinematic universe the marvel cinematic
universe
is rooted more in the ultimate universe
than it is in the main marvel continuity
there are some differences i mean there
are some main marvel timeline things
that are folded in for example
captain america steve rogers is the
first super soldier in the main marvel
universe but he's not the first super
soldier in the ultimate universe and
that actually brings us in
to the story of miles morales origin and
the reason why is because of the fact
that all of this basically deals with
norman osborn and osborne industries as
well as something called the oz formula
now the odds formula is just one of
several attempts in the ultimate
universe to basically duplicate the
original super soldier serum that made
nick fury and this is one of the biggest
differences when it came to the ultimate
universe and the main marvel universe
with regards to the
main marvel continuity you have what's
called weapons plus and weapons plus
is basically just this organization that
serves the purpose of creating super
soldiers to battle against credible
threats the idea was that captain
america steve rogers was weapon one that
was it but because of the fact that dr
abraham erskine the guy that was behind
the formula that made steve rogers into
a super soldier had basically been
killed
it was impossible to duplicate his
formula perfectly and so the idea was to
try to attempt it but if it didn't work
to also have
backup projects instead and so what we
got were projects two through nine and
that was everything from like you know
implanting cybernetic implants and like
animals trying to make animals sentient
it was a multitude of just different
things that all had to do with creating
super soldiers
eventually it led into weapon 10 or
weapon x which gave us wolverine which
led into like deadpool and you know all
different kinds of stuff but
all of it was rooted in the idea of
captain america steve rogers in the
ultimate universe
it's a wholly different kettle of beans
the way it all worked out is that
instead of steve rogers
nick fury was the very first super
soldier but much like captain america
steve rogers in the main marvel universe
the entire basis behind the super
soldier serum had basically gone up in
smoke nobody really knew how to
replicate it but what ended up happening
is different organizations across the
world began attempting to duplicate it
of course in canada for example they
were trying to duplicate the process
that made nick fury into a super soldier
and that resulted in them kidnapping
james hallett and discovering the x gene
which meant that if these x genes were
basically unlocked or they were accessed
people would be granted powers
and so once they access the powers of
james hallett then they in turn turn
this formula or what-have-you into an
aerosol form dispersed it across the
world and that's how mutants started
popping up when it came to
norman osborne and oz diaz formula that
was based off the
super soldier formula that was used to
make nick fury into a super soldier and
so the idea was that norman osborne was
trying to find a way to again create
super soldiers and in doing so
began the process of like radiating
spiders and so on and so forth one of
these spiders bit peter parker which led
to the start of the
ultimate spider-man line of stories now
that deals with the idea of like
mutants and most of the super-powered
community the idea was that in the
ultimate spider-man comics peter parker
had just gone forward you know as a
superhero
he was learning about his powers with
great power must come great
responsibility that he was taught by
uncle ben fast forwarding over the
course of his publication history once
we got into like 2011 2012
writer brian michael bendis wanted to
shift things up he wanted to basically
remove peter parker and put somebody in
his place the fact remains here
that in the instance of peter parker
effectively getting away the idea of
osborne was to basically figure out what
it was about the formula that gave peter
parker powers in the first place and
then
duplicate it now of course this all dead
ends into the idea of norman osborn
being revealed as the green goblin and
so on and so forth but then we actually
pick up with a guy by the name of
prowler now in the main marvel line of
stories
prowler is a guy named hobie brown and
you may have heard of his line of comics
he got his own solo series
as part of all new all different amazing
spider-man's clone conspiracy really the
biggest role that hobie brown plays in
all new all different marvel is he's the
stand-in spider-man when peter parker is
you know holding a press conference or
when he's in the middle of a meeting or
something like that
hobie brown is the one that parades
around is spider-man so that people
believe that peter and spider-man are
two distinctly different people
here in this ultimate universe line of
stories he's basically just the uncle of
miles morales he's just a guy and they
call him prowler because he's basically
just a guy that steals stuff but
breaking into osborne industries has its
own risks in the sense that
you're basically breaking into a
multinational corporation not only that
in the middle of this heist the spider
manages to make its way onto prowler
which in turn
enters his bag taking this spider with
him now from here
we pick up with miles morales and that's
one of the things that i like the most
about miles is that
miles the way his story was told the way
it was done by blind michael bendis
he was designed to basically be a
character that reflected the real world
and most of the ultimate universe was
like that the ultimate universe was
marvel coming along and saying okay
how can we take these characters that
everybody knows and everybody loves and
update them
for the modern day so they could
basically get an answer to the question
what if captain america emerged right
now that was the whole basis behind the
ultimate universe back when it was made
in the year 2000 and so the idea
is that miles morales is basically in a
lottery for a charter school there was a
good documentary that was done a while
ago called waiting for superman we said
either is waiting for superman or
waiting on superman but the idea was
that it dealt with like the american
school system and something that a lot
of you guys may not know
is that in a lot of like inner city
schools and really impoverished parts of
the country you'll have like the public
school system and then they'll open a
charter school which is like where you
can get the best education
in that particular school district and
they'll hold lotteries like people will
go
to like these huge assembly halls and
they'll basically start drawing numbers
and those kids who were selected
get to go to that charter school the
others are just left to deal with the
american school system i mean it's one
of those things where it's like if they
win and they get to go to a charter
school they'll have a future outside of
whatever education they get from the
american school system being as defunded
as it is so it's not really designed to
be like a political statement it's
designed to make uh miles morales
relatable and that's one of the things
that i kind of feel like needs to be
said especially right now in marvel
because a lot of people are looking at
the whole you know political landscape
and so on and so forth this was written
back in 2011
and so while brian michael bendis does
have a tendency to be a little political
with his writing this was not designed
to be a statement he was basically
designed to say
here's a relatable aspect of miles
morales because there are kids that deal
with this
every day of their life in inner city
areas so again it's kind of cool here
because as a kid who is part hispanic
part african-american it really related
to a lot of young people who were
reading his comics
because that really feeds into the
nature of spider-man keep in mind peter
parker's legacy was formed by the fact
that he basically empowered teenagers he
made young people feel like they were
the star of the show
and that legacy of spider-man lives on
because you get a little bit of the
humor but you also get that whole
backstory in terms of everything that
happened that made him who he was and so
with miles morales winning this
we're basically introduced to the idea
of his uncle miles does not
know about the role that his uncle plays
in being a thief for him his uncle is
just an uncle and so it's really just
kind of miles relaying the news and
and that kind of thing but the funny
scenario about this too is that miles
was really told in a lot of ways
do not go see your uncle his father had
explicitly laid that out do not go see
him on the regular he is
not a good influence now of course again
the whole idea of a thief but we'll
actually learn there's a little more
about miles dad
than we were originally given there's a
little bit of an expansion here but of
course
in the middle of all this he's basically
bitten by the radioactive spider that
his uncle had carried home
and then suddenly just wakes up now of
course with miles dad coming home
screaming at it you know at his brother
and that kind of thing miles basically
just takes off now
this is when we start to get into a lot
of the aspects of spider-man homecoming
just kind of going by the trailer she's
looking at what we've seen
you know with regards to the trailers
and the whole idea here is that
spider-man homecoming looks as though
it's just supposed to be rooted in like
the modern day it's supposed to be
rooted in a lot of like current things
that go on right now again
sort of feeding into this ultimate
universe thing but the introduction of
it all really kind of comes by way of
miles whole experience
and learning that he has powers the
other half of this is that when brian
michael bendis
made miles morales had he gone through
and made miles just
a total replica of peter parker it would
have cheapened it it would have taken
away the the impact of miles being
spider-man with miles one of the biggest
issues that he faces is a combination of
just kind of growing up
you know as being a teenager and also
the idea of having powers because
remember one of the relatable aspects of
this is just
teenage life and i don't know about you
guys i don't know how many of you guys
watching this are teenagers but being a
teenager i mean
in hindsight it's the easiest thing in
the world but at the time when you are a
teenager it seems like the hardest thing
in the world because you're trying to
make friends you're trying to be
socially acceptable you also want to be
able to drive around and have your own
independence but you also recognize
you're not necessarily ready for the
world but you think you are
there's a million things that go on in
your head i mean there's college there's
your future there's a million things
rolling around in your head
to say nothing of the fact that you're
basically spending you know five or six
years
going through an existential crisis who
are you where are you going what's your
purpose in the universe i mean these are
all the things that teenagers deal with
on a regular basis and so this combined
with the idea of the sudden introduction
of powers
makes things a little difficult now the
other half of this is a character by the
name of
genki and this is really the whole idea
of like ned leeds character being
brought in to spider-man homecoming one
of the funny situations and one of the
things that fans
immediately caught on when it came to
the trailer of spider-man homecoming
is the character of ned leeds
historically speaking in the peter
parker spider-man line of stories in the
main marvel universe
ned leeds was a bit was like a like a
competitor at the daily bugle he was
never a classmate of peter parker
with this introduction of ned leads in
spider-man homecoming
it's basically genki from the ultimate
universe in the sense that the two of
them relate to each other in the exact
same way genki is kind of like the the
comedic sidekick he's the kid who sort
of cheers spider-man or
you know cheers miles away and says look
man like you're capable of incredible
things but it's also the idea that genki
is going to be the moral compass for
miles morales
in a lot of different ways but it's kind
of cool because instead of just like
being terrified instead of being afraid
it's this idea that miles could achieve
something pretty incredible with the
powers that he has
and so in the middle of this whole
conversation that he has you know with
with genki he's basically pulled aside
by his father you know taken to a local
park and his father basically explains
the reason why he doesn't want miles
spending time with his uncle is because
of the fact that his uncle's a thief
and that's one of the greatest things
about this particular story is because
with peter parker spider-man in the main
marvel universe it's well uncle ben died
and then with great power must come
great responsibility and the moral
lessons that came with that with miles
morales it's a lot more visceral
it's this idea that his father basically
made a lot of bad decisions his father
stole at one point in time his father
served time in jail somewhere along the
line for him he looks at his son miles
and says you've just been accepted to a
charter school
you have a future you can get out of
this place but this also creates a bit
of a contradiction with miles himself
because in his mind in his imagination
he sees himself being spider-man he sees
himself crawling on walls which he
inevitably does he sees himself
saving the day and that's one of the
interesting things about this story
is because you know once he goes and
visits you know genki and kind of tells
him everything that's going on you know
kind of expands on the idea that he can
crawl on walls and so on and so forth
and once he actually travels you know
alongside genki and comes across
a fire in a building this creates the
kind of inner debate you know with miles
morales between what his father's
teaching him and what he's coming to
understand on his own his father's
looking at the big picture but his
father doesn't know that miles has
spider powers so in the mind of mile's
father it's
here's my son who lives in a pretty
rough part of town
who's just been accepted to a school
that will get him a future think of all
the things that he could do he'd become
a lawyer or a doctor or a businessman or
something along those lines
in the mind of miles morales with the
powers that he has he can save people on
the ground level
and that is the inherent difference
between what it is that miles father's
teaching
him and what miles can become miles
father is talking about playing a much
bigger role playing a much larger role
but when you're spider-man you know when
you are on the ground floor when you're
saving somebody from a burning building
you don't
say well hey we're passing some laws and
it's going to make people's life better
and it does
instead you see their faces you see
their immediate reactions you get thank
yous you get wow i can't believe you
pulled that off you get the adoration of
a community that comes to respect you as
you're able to
do things that make their lives tangibly
better that's the coolest thing about
that is because it makes it more
personal and so the struggle that miles
faces is that when he does rescue a kid
from a burning building
suddenly the gravity of the situation
begins to hit him because now he
realized he just saved a human life
and what that means is people will look
at him and they will say wow that guy's
a superhero man that kid's amazing i
can't believe he pulled that off but now
miles has to come to the realization
that the life of other people is in his
hands
what if he hadn't acted that little girl
probably would have burned to death in
that building but with miles morales
stepping in and saving her life then the
question becomes but what about the
lives that he inevitably just can't save
what if there's just not enough time for
him to get there what about the person
who's being mugged or being attacked
that he doesn't know about
how does all that play into the equation
peter parker spider-man in the main
marvel universe
deals with that by realizing that while
he tries to save everybody he can he
cannot save
everyone you can't be everywhere it
wants that's one of the reasons why
superior spider-man was so cool because
he was everywhere once he had eyes all
throughout the entire city but with
miles morales he's coming to realize
that you can't be everywhere at one time
you can't save everyone there are some
people out there that you just can't do
anything with and so what we end up
doing is we basically pick up with the
moment by which
peter parker ends up dying in the
ultimate universe and again this was a
pretty
big moment in the whole ultimate
spider-man story just because you gotta
remember i mean the ultimate universe
was basically
launched with peter parker spider-man
and so for about a decade or so
if you were reading ultimate spider-man
you were reading peter parker and the
way that he went out was actually pretty
amazing i mean it was like this battle
with norman osborne and you know he
basically fought to the point that he
died it was almost like this
superman-esque scenario where it was
basically just like a battle to the
death
but in the midst of all this what it
does is it basically sets the groundwork
for peter parker to be removed from the
entire spider-man mythos and it allows
miles morales to effectively take his
place now something to point out here
is that with miles being on the scene
and directly you know speaking with gwen
stacy when stacey really just kind of in
a moment of of mourning sort of spits
out the name of peter parker but what it
does is it basically kind of lights this
fire in miles morales because with miles
morales seeing
everything happen when he sees the death
of peter parker he really just kind of
looks at this and says well now it's up
to me to do something
his discussion with genki is look i
didn't get these powers even if that got
him by chance i have to believe
if anybody had these powers they would
put them to use they would live up to
the legacy as it was created by
spider-man they would live up to
everything it was that he did that that
peter parker had effectively done
and so in the mind of miles that's when
he begins to really understand
what it is that he's meant to do the
significance of the role that he plays
in being spider-man because going to the
funeral of peter parker
speaking with aunt may speaking with
gwen stacy it's basically this question
that he asked
why did he become spider-man what was
the motivation of it and this is the
beauty of this because gwen stacy
immediately as angry as she is
goes and basically says he did
everything that he did because his uncle
instilled in him with great power
must come great responsibility those
with the power to act
have the responsibility to act and that
is one of the reasons why the spider-man
mythos has always been so great and one
of the reasons why it's so important
when it comes to different superheroes
over the years they all have their own
moral compasses their own motivations
for why it is they do the things they do
with superman it was this idea that he
was taught by jonathan demartha ken if
you have the power to stop crime
you should stop crime in some form or
fashion it was always this measure of
responsibility but with the infamous
phrase
with great power must come great
responsibility it made it tangible we've
all heard that right like
do the right thing even if no one is
watching or something along those lines
we've all had that moral compass
instilled in us but to have gwen stacy
say this to miles morales
in this way it lights a fire in miles
morales because he's just like that's
true it's an honest statement i have
these abilities and so in his mind while
he goes through and designs his own
little spinal
spider-man suit the idea is i have to
keep the memory of spider-man going and
this is actually
one of the first mistakes that he makes
because what they do is they grab a
spider-man halloween costume
and he immediately takes to the streets
now this is one of those things where
it's just too early bro it's just
it's just way too early despite miles
more alice wanting to do the right thing
his heart's in the right place
the mistake that he makes is that
everybody looks at him as trying to be
like a copycat of spider-man but people
are still in the morning phase you gotta
keep in mind with the idea of spider-man
losing such a hero
in such a tragic way people aren't ready
to see somebody just suddenly take up
the mantle they're not ready to see
somebody just suddenly become spider-man
what they want
is time to grieve what they want is time
to mourn and once that time has passed
then they'll be ready for somebody to
take up the mantle and so at this point
it's just
too much too fast and so in the middle
of this whole experience that he has
running around the streets dressed as
spider-man he's basically met with the
arrival
of jessica drew now jessica drew is
actually a pretty interesting character
in the realm of marvel comics and the
reason why is because
she originally appeared in marvel's
spotlight in 1977 i think it was and she
was actually a character who basically
gained her spider powers by way of a
direct injection from her father and it
was really just a weird circumstance it
was essentially that she had just been
you know irradiated by uranium that was
you know across the land and so on and
her father basically tried to cure of
her
uranium poisoning by injecting her with
a serum that was composed of different
spiders and then putting her in this
sort of evolution chamber that was
created by the high evolutionary who
messed around with the evolution of
animals and stuff like that she woke up
something like decades later and
basically just kind of emerged with no
idea who she was and eventually joined
hydra or something like that but with
the ultimate universe
it's a wholly different kettle of beans
and so jessica drew in the ultimate
universe is actually a clone of peter
parker and that's one of the interesting
things is because
with her character despite people
knowing who she was she wasn't
so significant in the realm of marvel
comics that they kind of had to tiptoe
around and be careful about what they
did she wasn't captain america she
wasn't thor she wasn't like iron man or
anything like that and so because of
that it offered marvel a little bit of
leeway in terms of
what they did with their character how
they wrote her how they designed her so
on and so forth also because of the fact
that the clone saga from marvel comics
was not a very well received story for a
lot of people and so the idea of going
back and reworking it in the ultimate
universe was actually kind of cool
it was actually pretty interesting but
with her confronting miles morales this
comes by way of the fact that she was
basically told by nick fury there's
somebody out there
impersonating spider-man that happened
within you know the a wholly separate
line of stories but the fact remains
that with nick fury basically being the
director
of shield and then essentially having
all this information on the life and
times of miles the cool thing is that
there's a conversation that takes place
between the two of them you know where
nick fury basically says look
i know your heart's in the right place i
know you're trying to do the right thing
but people
are not ready for a new spider-man yet
give them time give them a little bit of
time they'll come around but for right
now all they see you as is a cheap
knockoff
because you're wearing the exact same
uniform that spider-man wore so
if you are going to be spider-man if
you're going to be a superhero then
you've got to be different you can't
just be peter parker you've got to be
your own character and that was kind of
like an
in-comic book a statement by brian
michael bendis effectively saying miles
morales
is his own character he's wholly
different from peter parker they're two
distinctly different characters and that
was one of the interesting things
is because again it was hitting home at
the idea that he basically sort of gone
away and so what ended up happening is
that you know of course with electro
maxwell dylan basically being one of the
most notable villains of the ultimate
spider-man
making his escape miles morales is
single-handedly responsible
for basically being able to bring him
down now the ultimates are there you
know the ultimate universe avengers are
there and they do what they can
but it's really miles morales that pulls
it off through a combination of his
ability to make himself
invisible and the fact that he issues
this sort of electrical touch
whatever it is that he engages somebody
now the reason why that works is because
what it does
is it basically sends the electrical
impulses of electro into
overdrive and really just sort of hyper
drives them and then just shuts them
down he's basically overwhelmed by his
own powers but you know with him being
shot dead by nick fury as a way to kind
of curtail his character a little bit
what happens
is it's basically miles morales showing
the ultimates that he's actually pretty
legit
you know he's got what it takes to not
only be a member of the team but to also
stand on his own two feet as his own
superhero
now at this point he's not part of the
ultimate avengers yet i mean he hasn't
really been
rolled in as part of the ranks just
because one he doesn't have the
experience and two
they just don't know enough about him
but the first step to allowing the
the ultimates to gain more information
about him to see what he's about is reno
really comes by way of nick fury who
presents miles morales with an actual
spider-man costume based on mile's own
designs when he was just kind of drawing
up these little versions of his own
costume when he was trying to figure out
what he was going to look like
nick fury basically used shield's
resources found this design i don't know
broke into his home i have no clue
but took this costume made it real and
gave it to miles and said now go forward
and be your own superhero
okay so getting into ultimate spider-man
or i guess really miles more alice
ultimate spider-man one thing i want to
point out here is that in these video
titles i'm simply going to call these
miles more alice ultimate spider-man and
you know volume 1 volume 2 volume 3 and
so on really the origin story that we
did
is volume 1 so this is more like volume
2. but in truth this was really just
kind of called
ultimate spider-man and then there was
another series later on that followed
this that was called
miles morales ultimate spider-man but in
order to avoid confusion between
ultimate spider-man peter parker and
ultimate spider-man miles morales we're
just gonna call this
ultimate spider-man miles morales so
that way everything's pretty clear and
pretty easy to follow but the cool thing
about this is that again the origin
story for those of you guys who are just
joining us with regards to the whole
ultimate spider-man landscape
the ultimate universe was never designed
to be this great big huge grandiose
thing
like the main marvel universe i mean the
main marvel universe was really kind of
built by stan lee
jack kirby steve ditko a handful of
other writers and artists in the 1960s
and 70s and then it grew to what it is
now where it's just
massive in scope and you have the
avengers and you have you know excalibur
and you have alpha flight and you have
you know the brotherhood of evil mutants
and the x-men and so on and so forth the
ultimate universe was designed to be far
more contained
and much much smaller in scale and so
the result is that when it came to the
ultimate spider-man stories by
brian michael bendis the idea was to
basically keep things relatively small
to tell these small volumes where
characters would appear and then never
be seen or heard from again or else if
they were seen they were just in a
containment cell where they were being
held by shield or something along those
lines but it was very easy to digest and
it was very very easy to follow and
that's one of the reasons
why the ultimate universe was relatively
popular but in the end people still
gravitated toward the characters that
they thought of when they
thought of captain america when they
thought of thor and so on and so forth
now with regards to miles morales
peter parker was basically the recipient
of a bite from
a spider that contained the oz formula
and again the whole idea here in the
ultimate universe was that nick fury i
guess samuel jackson nick figure if you
want to call him that
nick fury was the original super soldier
and when the super soldier's serum that
was used on nick fury proved to be
successful it resulted
in this great gold rush more or less for
everybody to create their own super
soldiers and so that's where wolverine
came from wolverine was the recipient of
canada's attempt to create a super
soldier serum but along the way
they discovered a mutant gene that when
activated would give people powers and
that was the origin of the mutant race
in the ultimate universe when it came to
spider-man
you had a guide norman osborne who was
basically trying to create a super
soldier serum and he created something
called the oz formula and where he was
going through and testing it on
different spiders one of these fighters
bit peter parker which led him to become
spider-man in the ultimate universe but
following the course of his publication
history somewhere around 160 issues or
so which this is
far shorter than that i think miles
morales stories probably total in like
maybe
30 or 40 issues it's not really that
long at all but uh following the
publication history of peter parker he
eventually died
and the reason was because marvel was
wanting to basically make way for a new
spider-man and that just made good sense
i mean you had
ultimate spider-man peter parker and
then you had the main marvel universe
peter parker why have two versions of
the same character give us a new
spider-man and so that's what they did
they killed off peter parker and they
had a spider basically bite a new kid by
the name of miles morales who gained
peter parker's powers and then a couple
of his own that peter didn't have for
example miles morales can administer
this venom
venom shock which is basically kind of
like an electrical impulse that
basically shocks a person that's
touching him or something along those
lines he can make himself invisible he
can camouflage himself that kind of a
thing and so again miles was very much
his own character but the whole idea
here and really where the story begins
to pick up as we start to get into
uh his uncle aaron davis now the crazy
thing about aaron davis character is
that as interesting as he is
there's a lot more to him than meets the
eye it's not as clean cut as him just
being a con man but that's how he comes
off he comes off as a con artist
he comes off as a thief and a cheat but
he's actually a very capable guy
and the way this story unfolds is it's
actually going to be a sort of a battle
of allegiances so to speak for miles
morales himself but what ends up
happening here
is we actually pick up with aaron davis
traveling back or at least intending to
meet the tinker now the tinkerer is
basically a character
who creates devices i mean really the
tinkerer was who we saw in the
spider-man homecoming movie that was
working alongside michael keaton the
other half of this is that it also deals
with the introduction of
a new version of the scorpion and the
reason why i say new version is because
of the fact that in the
peter parker ultimate spider-man line of
comics and those stories the scorpion
was introduced but he was actually
introduced as a clone of peter parker
the issue with this was that with brian
michael bendis writing the story at the
time and wanting to create a new
spider-man
it also made sense to give this new
spider-man miles morales
his own villains to face off against and
so what ended up happening
is uh the scorpion as he appeared in the
original peter parker stories in the
ultimate universe
he was basically defeated he was
revealed to be a clone of peter parker
and then he was just never really seen
or heard from again after he was taken
captive by shield that was really it
this version of scorpion seems to be
more in line with the scorpion that we
saw from spider-man homecoming this
scorpion seems to be more grounded in
terms of who he is and what he's about
and that kind of a thing his backstory
still remains pretty ambiguous and it
will for a little while but suffice it
to say
he's basically in new york because of
the fact that prowler owes him cash
and that's really about it now the other
half of this is miles morales trying to
make his way
and trying to figure out how to be a
superhero but the other thing to focus
on here is that miles is struggling with
the exact same thing that peter parker
did and that's one of the cool things
about this
is that what vendors and them are
basically saying is that no matter what
universe we're in for the most part
unless the character is
drastically different from who we're
used to he's always going to struggle
with the same thing
should he tell his friends and family
who he is and if he does
what are the consequences of that
because remember if he were to tell his
mom for example that he's spider-man she
may believe him she may not believe him
but if she has that knowledge
it makes her a target for somebody else
and so she basically can't spill the
beans on something she doesn't know
anything about and if miles never tells
her then nobody has any reason to go
after her they have no reason to connect
the two people now something else to
focus on is that again when bendis and
then created miles morales they didn't
just abandon the concept of peter parker
in his entirety i mean he's dead he
doesn't show up and he won't show up
again until spider-man
but the idea here was to keep the legacy
of peter parker going
genki really just kind of goes to miles
and says look it's cool that you're
spider-man but you don't really know
what you're doing
and peter parker's not here to teach you
what you need to know because he's dead
and so you need to be able to learn what
peter parker knew
from peter parker himself the best way
you know how which is to basically watch
movies of peter parker fighting and
that's kind of the cool thing because
you know miles gets a video gets to
watch a you know watch footage of the
ultimate universe peter parker facing
off against doctor octopus nothing too
significant
but his first real attempt in trying to
stand toe-to-toe and trying to really
become
spider-man comes with the arrival of a
character by the name of omega red now
omega red in the ultimate universe was
starkly different from his character in
the
in the main marvel universe in the main
marvel universe omega red was the
byproduct of the russians
trying to duplicate wolverine that's
really all it was it was the idea that
wolverine had been taken by the weapon x
project his healing factor had been used
in order to bond his body with
adamantium and the result was that he
ended up going forward as just this
adamantium laced killing machine the
russians tried to duplicate the same
process
but the difference here is that the
russians didn't know the formula for
adamantium and so because of that they
ended up creating a cheap knockoff
called
carbonadium now carbonation is still
pretty durable and it's still pretty
potent in terms of what it's capable of
but naturally this eventually led to a
battle of sorts between omega red and
wolverine with the two of them becoming
mortal enemies in the ultimate universe
it was starkly different omega red was
basically just a guy who was a mutant he
gained these powers that allowed him to
just kind of expand these organic
tendrils from his body he could emit
toxins different things like that but he
wasn't nearly as capable as his main
marvel counterpart but the reason why
this is important is because of the fact
that for
miles more alice going against somebody
like omega red
is going against someone he's never
experienced before and so it's really
him kind of on the edge of his seat
using his powers as best he can
trying to become a legitimate hero
because with trying to dodge these
tendrils and so on it requires him to
use basically
every ounce of agility he has as you
would expect he comes out on top
but the idea of aaron davis being rolled
in as part of miles morales spider-man
story comes when again aaron davis
basically encounters the tinkerer and
it's the idea that the tinkerer you know
when aaron davis is looking at this
newspaper about a new spider-man and so
on and so forth the tinkerer basically
gives aaron davis the whole backstory of
how spider-man
became spider-man the original peter
parker became spider-man of course as we
talked about norman osborne created the
odds formula so on and so forth
but this also rings a bell for the
prowler because remember in our video on
the origin of miles morales he was
bitten by
a spider in front of uncle aaron davis
and the result was that aaron davis saw
the spider and saw
a number on it and so because of that
when you know tinkerer begins to explain
all these things about what osborne was
doing how he would perform experiments
on these spiders he would number them
and he would catalog them in order to
keep track of what his experiments were
doing and how they were progressing
aaron davis comes to the realization
that a numbered spider bit his nephew
and then suddenly there's this new
spider-man on the scene
two and two together miles morales is
spider-man and that's why i say that
parlor aaron davis is actually sharper
than people give him credit for i mean
he's smarter than your average bear i
guess but it's kind of a cool thing
because it sets the stage for this idea
of aaron davis being brought in
asking for some pretty nefarious things
and that's really the first thing that
he does i mean as soon as he realizes
that miles is spider-man he goes to him
and says hey man like we should work
together like we can put our efforts
together and we can really achieve
something great now remember
miles was informed by his father that
his uncle aaron was a cr
was a con artist and a crook and served
time in jail mile's father was heading
down the same path and so
mile's father had basically warned him
hey look do not get in the mix with your
uncle aaron the other half of this is
that mile's father
i wouldn't go as far as to say is a very
cautious man so much as he's trying to
ensure his son stays safe but he's also
a little overprotective and this is
where the whole element
of loyalties begins to come into play
because with miles morales he's kind of
stuck in two different situations the
first
is that he believes in his father i mean
it's his dad you know he follows his
father as best he can
but it almost feels like his father's
trying to shelter him from the world's
experiences and life in and of itself
people growing and becoming something
better than they are
is all about experiences doing something
stupid and learning from that experience
at the same time it's his uncle aaron
davis and he knows that he's a crook
but if he wants to go out and experience
life there's a lot of different ways to
do that but family is family blood is
blood and so again that's one of the
interesting things about this this story
and that's one of the reasons why i've
loved
miles morales character for so long is
because it's just the inner struggle
between the two of them now with regards
to aaron davis having killed the tinker
so that nobody would know
about the the possibility of miles
morales being ultimate spider-man uh it
also comes into play with him
i guess re-encountering scorpion again
and this is when we basically learned
that
scorpion was owed money by aaron davis
that presumably aaron davis essentially
cheated him out of cash
scorpion comes back looking for his
money now the other half of this is that
we also get some perspective in terms of
what scorpion's capable of and what
we're actually informed here is that
he's not just some crazy guy you know
who is a mob boss out of mexico
instead he does have some abilities and
one of the most notable
is a highly resistant skin aaron davis
ultimately just ends up fleeing for his
life when he begins to realize just how
capable scorpion is and then he's not
really a pushover now of course this
leads to exactly what we would expect it
to in the sense that aaron davis
essentially
flees to his nephew miles morales and
this is probably one of the best
elements of the story and the reason for
this is because aaron davis approaching
his nephew
is done from ill intent like it's him
showing up and essentially having this
ulterior motive there's a guy trying to
kill me i want to try to take him out so
on and so forth but he doesn't say that
he doesn't go to miles morales and say
hey man
i did something really bad i screwed a
guy over in mexico and he got here to
new york and he's trying to kill me
you got to help me take this guy out
that's not what he says instead what he
does is he pawns it off on the idea
of being a tutor of sorts and that's
kind of the cool thing because aaron
davis uses you know basically the
abilities of a suit combined with his
own experiences
to engage miles in hand-to-hand combat
and this is why i say
sometimes despite the fact that there
can be nefarious purposes here
at the end of the day there is still
something to be learned
and so while aaron davis is trying to
manipulate his own nephew aaron davis
is teaching miles how to become a more
effective fighter because remember miles
doesn't have any martial arts training
he doesn't have military training he has
no kind of training at all he's a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and then suddenly has all these powers
and so he doesn't know how to fight he
doesn't have any of that kind of
training stuff he's really
just flying by the seat of his pants
every step of the way in every single
conflict he gets into now the other half
is to remember
he learns as he goes through and that's
kind of the cool thing is because he's
literally
learning to fight while he's fighting
and so that's one of the
the crazy things about his character and
his evolution but the idea of aaron
davis is saying look i'm trying to help
you out here now aaron is not totally
evil like he's not a total bad guy he's
not just like i don't care whether you
live or die i'm just trying to make sure
that this guy
scorpion gets off my back instead it's
really this idea that he's going to him
and he's saying look i don't want to see
you killed and that really is one of the
reasons why aaron davis character is so
intricate and
is so complex is because on one half
he's a thief he's a con artist he's a
manipulator but at the other half
that's family that's his nephew the last
spider-man was
killed by his own enemies it'd be a lot
easier for miles rounds to be killed by
different foes because he doesn't have
nearly the experience or the training
that peter parker had and so again it's
kind of a cool scenario now of course
ultimately miles is able to overcome
aaron davis to the point that he proves
that he's able to hold his own to a
degree and this is where the
conversation begins to unfold is because
aaron davis basically says i want to
train you i want to make you a good
fighter i want to turn you into somebody
who can be a legitimate superhero and
this is why it's kind of this idea that
these two characters have conflicting
sides where you know aaron davis is just
kind of a small time crook and a con man
and miles morales is trying to be a good
guy
at the end of the day they have a common
goal and the common goal
is to take out an even worse bad guy
named scorpion and so that's the common
ground that the two of them reside on at
this moment it allows the characters to
sort of progress and to grow and so on
and so forth and so
where we ultimately have miles just kind
of perusing the internet and trying to
learn about this scorpion character and
we eventually have him just sort of
mulling this entire situation over
and then ultimately agreeing to side
with his uncle aaron
against the wishes of his parents after
learning that this guy scorpion has
engaged in acts of racketeering
murder theft violating other human
beings this guy is just a genuinely
terrible human being and so because of
that you know ultimately miles ends up
siding with us with his uncle which
again sets the stage for some pretty
cool stuff but
okay uh so we are a couple weeks out
from
the release of the playstation 5 and
miles morales spider-man uh spider-man
miles morales i guess is what they're
calling it whatever it is the spider-man
2 game uh and here's the thing okay
i'm actually kind of sad about this uh
myself and mariah have not pre-ordered
like we didn't get a chance to pre-order
the ps5
right the pre-orders were out like that
like it was it was insane uh so here's
the deal
are there any members of the rob corps
in columbus ohio
that can hook up myself and mariah with
playstation 5.
i'll give you like an extra 200 bucks
plus the cost of the playstation 5s if
you can hook us up
uh that would be awesome right that'd be
that'd be super cool if you can send me
an email rob at comics explaining.com
that would be amazing i don't know if
any of you guys can uh we'll even go as
far as cleveland if we have to
but uh that'd be awesome if you guys
could right so um
it's been a little while since we
covered miles morales right we covered
the first two and i think we did it like
three years ago so we're gonna do a
little bit of catch up here
for people who are are really uncertain
and who are kind of lagging behind
in the midst of all this so miles
morales becoming spider-man
came out of what was basically like
cataclysm to a degree right it was it
was basically this great big huge story
arc
in in the ultimate universe where that
version of spider-man had died right so
a little bit of explanation here the
ultimate universe
was launched in 2000 and it was the
answer to the question what would it
look like if superheroes existed in the
real world right a more modern depiction
of superheroes as we know them in marvel
comics the ultimate universe was hugely
popular and it was basically launched
with ultimate spider-man right with
peter parker now when peter parker died
spider-man fans were pissed right they
were so mad because they loved that
version of spider-man and as we know as
comic book fans we don't really like it
when things change right we like things
to stay the same
forever and ever and ever because when
things are different it takes us getting
used to it again and we just don't want
to have to go through all that
you know we got we're old people right
we just get stuck in our ways and the
results of this
is that when miles morales initially
came onto the scene there was a lot of
hate for the character of miles the
funny thing is he's hugely popular now
so much so that like one he's got his
own game and two i've heard nothing but
people being excited about the new miles
morales game right so as with most
things in comics give it time
and you may end up finding that you like
it but the whole thing behind this
is that in the early days and kind of in
the beginning of this miles morales
having been bitten by a spider that gave
him radioactive powers in much the same
way that peter parker did was met with a
lot of backlash
in the ultimate comics universe right
like in the actual comics themselves
because peter parker had like just died
and then miles you know in order to
honor the memory of peter went out and
got a spider-man suit and then was like
okay uh let's let's be spider-man right
he was met by like nick fury he was met
by uh jessica drew or whatever you want
to call her basically the ultimate
universe version of spider-girl
spider-woman
and and they were kind of like you can't
do this right like you're disrespecting
the memory of peter but the reality was
that miles believed that he was honoring
the memory of peter
right he believed he was doing the right
thing and so ultimately he ended up
getting the blessing of nick fury and
then this led to the introduction of the
prowler right the parlor was a character
who had already been around and the
prowler was basically
uh the the uncle of miles morales uh he
was basically aaron
right and and the idea behind this was
that you ended up having uh miles
basically allying himself with aaron uh
out of uh you know as
part of aaron's request now when miles
sort of realized and the things were a
little sketchy here that's when all this
kind of started popping off right but
this this really is kind of like when
the two of them first start teaming up
we as the reader knew
that aaron was a bad guy right like we
knew he was basically a villain he was
one of the most wanted men
in the united states and in fact he was
wanted by interpol and the fbi right
like it was a huge deal
again it's probably one of the best
thieves if not the best thief in the
entirety of the ultimate universe he was
kind of a big deal now with him and
miles teaming up for the first time
this involves them going after a guy by
the name of scorpion a marvel in in
the ultimate universe you had two
versions of the scorpion character and
you're probably familiar with him from
like maybe spider-man the animated
series back in the 90s or comic books or
whatever the case is
but the scorpion that you initially saw
in ultimate comics was part of the
ultimate universe line of the clone saga
right like cloning peter parker that's
where you know the
jessica character came from and so on
but the scorpion was a clone of peter
parker right so that was kind of like
that version that we saw
i wouldn't go as far as to say he was
hugely popular i honestly didn't really
enjoy the whole concept but the the
thing about this
is that this version of scorpion that we
see here is the guy who's actually named
maximus gargan right so his name is
almost identical to the one from the
main marvel universe
max gargan the difference here is that
unlike matt gargan and the main marvel
universe who's just a guy who's a
criminal uh and then in the ultimate
universe
maximus gargan was basically a mexican
crime lord
is essentially what he was he was like a
mexican drug kingpin but he was working
for
prowler and so essentially you had this
kind of exchange that was supposed to go
on between the two of them but basically
maximus gargan ended up turning on the
prowler it led into a great big huge
fight prowler basically got out of there
and then maximus has come here to new
york city in order to make himself a
kingpin and because of the fact that he
was able to overcome prowler before
the indication is he can do it again
right so he's not too worried about the
prowler's character but that's why
they're here
it's because aaron is trying to get rid
of maximus or trying to get rid of
scorpion because scorpion's encroaching
on his turf
the the idea that he's pitching to miles
morales is he's a bad guy right so we
got to get rid of bad guys so he's
essentially using miles desire to be a
hero in order
to effectively turn miles into his own
enforcer is really kind of what's
happening here but scorpion showing up
here and just being like okay so like
you know this is my this this is my spot
now but like i'm taking over this like i
was a guy who operated
in mexico that's true but like now i
want to swim with the bigger fish right
and so i'm taking the entirety of new
york over i'm going to become its new
kingpin
the the funny thing about this is that
he's immediately met by aaron right he's
immediately met by the prowler
and in turn the prowler is like okay so
like you gotta go
right you gotta you gotta go now the
response of of scorpion is like you
still owe me payment right like you
still owe me
for our last deal that went down
technically that's true that that when
that deal initially went down
that aaron was the one who refused to
love to his end of the bargain now he
did so under the auspices that scorpion
tried to double cross him
right and saying like you forfeited your
share of this whole thing when he tried
to double cross me but technically a
deal is a deal and so the result of this
is that you know
scorpion's here to kind of call in his
in and take out the prowler if he can
and then take over new york himself now
of course
this leads to spider-man jumping in now
there are questions that you're most
likely asking here
right where are characters like
daredevil or like luke cage
or heroes for hire or any of the number
of ground level heroes that we see
in new york that could easily respond to
a threat like this the reality of the
ultimate universe guys is that it was
designed to be a far more stripped down
version of the main marvel universe
the main marvel universe just to give
you perspective had like
thousands of mutants who had appeared
over the course of marvel's publication
history and those are the ones that they
focus on for any real measure of time
when you take into account the one-offs
the ones who appeared for like a single
story then you're starting to get into
the hundreds of thousands right there
were just you know
so many different mutants that had
appeared and so you take that and you
expand it to like the almost
never-ending roster of avengers you add
in things like
the midnight suns right you add in like
you know doctor strange's black ops
defenders team from like the 1990s right
they carried out like all these secret
missions and things like that
it was super cool it was an awesome
concept it was terribly executed but it
was an awesome concept but you take all
these things and you throwing it in and
what you end up in the main marvel
universe you end up with this just
hugely expansive landscape of heroes and
it's
insanely difficult to keep up with it
all the ultimate universe wanted to
correct
that right so you have like the ultimate
you've got the fantastic four you've got
the x-men
you got spider-man and that's basically
it right you see other characters kind
of pop in and out but you weren't really
seeing like ultimate comics
blade right you weren't really seeing
that you weren't really seeing like
ultimate comics werewolf by night
you weren't really seeing any of that
stuff right any of like these characters
that would have been interesting to see
instead it was designed to be super
closed down i would say
that overall in terms of individual
publications right individual comic book
lines i think you may be capped out
at 20 comics over the course of the
ultimate universe's lifespan and i'd say
that's probably about it
if that right it was very very very very
small
seeing other characters would happen in
other characters comics things like
that right so just just one of the you
know kind of an answer to that question
you know why don't we see
a lot more going on here uh because it's
not designed to be overly huge right
it's one of the great things about the
ultimate universe
but of course this is when things pop
off
basically you know everybody pulls guns
guns blazing shots firing
everything's going all to pieces now
this is when we kind of get reminded a
little bit of the
of the scorpion's powers right and make
sure you guys check down in the
description just kind of a reminder make
sure you check down in the description
you'll find uh ultimate spider-man uh
really the first two videos that we did
volumes one and two you'll find that
down there so you can get caught up and
you won't feel like you're just kind of
flying in out of nowhere but uh but the
idea behind scorpion is that he has
enhanced durability and enhanced
strength now he's not completely
invulnerable and he doesn't have like
super human strength right where he's
like equal to the incredible hulk and
strength or anything like that he's just
kind of got enhanced abilities but
they're enough to where he can easily
hold his own against like you know
being shot at or being stabbed or
something along those lines right so he
doesn't really have luke cage's skin
but something reasonably close to it the
other part of this is that given his
enhanced abilities he also is able to go
toe-to-toe with miles morales but the
reason why this happens
is because miles is still learning about
his powers right he's still learning
what he's capable of now
a lot of miles ability to expand beyond
his existing horizons will actually come
in the first
spider-man story which we will cover
that's basically it was it was really
cool it was when bendis basically told
all the miles morales haters to shut up
when they were like
he can't he's not really spider-man ben
venice literally wrote a story where
peter parker from the main marvel
universe and miles morales from the
ultimate universe and and peter parker
is like who cares what the world says uh
i think you're a great spider-man
go forward right and it's basically ben
is saying hey i know you guys some of
you guys out there don't like miles more
alice tough luck and then just like
continuing to write the story it was
amazing it was a hilarious response to
the haters but the
the funny thing about this is that miles
is learning his powers and so when it
comes to somebody like peter but if we
look at like even the ultimate universe
comics version of spider-man peter
parker or you look at the main marvel
universe version of spider-man peter
parker the important thing is that in
the early days he had his learning
he had his process where he learned his
powers but as time went on it started to
become second nature to where he could
just react and instinctively know what
he needs to do you know that's one of
the things that kind of came out of dan
slot's run
is when he was talking about why
spider-man would crack jokes all the
time because where you kind of looked at
it and saw spider-man as
almost kind of a nonsensical character
you know when he was engaging in in
fights and didn't really seem to be
taking it seriously the reason why he
would crack jokes is because he wanted
to make the villains think he wasn't
taking them seriously and that in turn
would piss them off and the angrier they
got
the less focused they became and the
easier it would be for peter parker to
take them out that's one of the things
that he kind of learned over the course
of his time as spider-man
with miles morales it'll be much the
same way that as we cover these comics
you'll quite literally see miles
become better at being spider-man but in
these early comics here in this third
volume of his original run he doesn't
really know what he's doing
he doesn't really have any official
training and that's really what he was
told by nick fury when nick fury
sanctioned him as being spider-man he's
like you're on your own to figure out
how to be a superhero we're not going to
train you right we're not going to give
you like official training at least not
at the moment we're not going to do any
of that right like you just got to
become the best version of spider-man
that you
can on your own and if you really are
meant to be a great spider-man then you
will become one if not then you'll
probably suck and you'll probably end up
getting killed
best of luck and that was basically it
[Laughter]
it was kind of a dick move but you know
ultimately one of the things that miles
ends up doing
is underestimating uh scorpion right in
the sense that he's able to overcome him
for a minute and where aaron wants to
get his revenge on
on scorpion the response of miles is no
it's one thing to stop a criminal it's
another to go out of your way and try to
kill the guy
right like that's not going to do
anybody any good and and ultimately
miles ends up intending to kind of walk
away now scorpion wakes up
scorpion attacks miles miles goes
invisible he attacks scorpion again and
then when miles turns his back
scorpion gets away and so it's one of
these things where he's constantly
underestimating
the villains that he faces off against
but that's because he simply hasn't
learned
that you have to make sure that they're
knocked out right like you know that's
one of the things that peter kind of
learned right as time went on that like
as he would face off against different
villains he would realize just because
they look like they're knocked out
doesn't mean they are right you just
gotta you gotta pummel them a few extra
times but you gotta
you know smack them around a little bit
more than you normally would and then
you know then they'll be knocked out and
that'll
that'll basically be it you know you
gotta slap him around a bit is is kind
of what what peter parker would do but
of course this leads to
to of course you know miles morales
tracking down uh trucking down scorpion
going to attack him again
and then using his uh his venom blast
right to essentially incapacitate him
this kind of venom shock
ability that he has to incapacitate uh
scorpion and then handing scorpion over
to the cops now the response to the
police officers
is to initially try to arrest miles
morales and that is
the way his comics were earl in the
early days right and
it wasn't really like a racial thing it
wasn't like he's wearing a black
spider-man costume
obviously he's black get him it wasn't
necessarily like that it was this idea
that they didn't know him like when
peter parker first showed up on the
scene
in a lot of ways it was kind of a
welcoming thing now a lot of that was
because of the fact that it was
spider-man right and nobody wants to
really read comics where the world hates
spider-man and then two
uh because it was kind of the launch of
the ultimate universe right so it was
designed to be kind of a celebratory
run you know this this kind of
celebratory inaugural run in peter now
he did run into a whole bunch of
problems
and there were times when society was
kind of like ah you know but nonetheless
you know with miles morales in a lot of
ways
the the writing the how the cops are
depicted here is designed to kind of
depict the naysayers right in the sense
that he's not spider-man we don't really
know what's going on here but get rid of
him you know he's not legit uh and so as
a result of that of course he makes
himself invisible and ends up taking off
right ends up you know kind of going
back to where aaron and them were
looking to find aaron and aaron
basically disappeared now the next day
you end up getting miles meeting up with
genki right meeting up with yankee lee
the two of them kind of talking you know
and he's like dude you busted like
maximus right you busted uh he busted
the scorpion like he's this this huge
thing and then that's when he starts
talking to uh to his uncle aaron and his
uncle aaron's like he's like where'd you
go he's like i'm gonna go get some rest
are you okay and you know it's like okay
like we're just getting started right
like we're gonna get back to this again
and and miles initial idea is no like i
don't want to be involved in this right
and that's when aaron kind of breaks out
that that blackmail card in the sense of
like i want to like then maybe i should
hit up your dad right maybe i should
tell your dad what's going on now that's
a little bit of backstory that we
haven't really explained yet the idea
was that aaron
of course has kind of always been a
criminal his whole life uh it started
out with him just kind of getting into
mischief when he was younger and then
graduating into
you know more more intense and and uh
more not really violent
uh but more serious crimes the father of
miles
was involved in that to a degree but
eventually went his own separate way
right he kind of went you know
basically went on the right path kind of
corrected himself and got himself into a
better place the result of this
is that uh the father miles does not
like aaron and he does not want aaron to
have any involvement in mile's life and
he's made that clear to miles right like
do not spend time with your uncle he's a
bad guy right like he's a criminal like
if you follow him like he will get you
into trouble he doesn't care about
anybody he doesn't care about anything
if he can if he
leads you to believe that he cares about
you it's because he's duping you right
like he's using you for his own ends and
so that's one of the things that kind of
went on here is that miles
knew he wasn't really supposed to be
spending time with aaron but he has been
anyway the other part of this is that
miles parents
don't know anything about his powers
right they don't know that he's
spider-man and so he's kind of trying to
keep this secret from them now it's one
of these things where aaron knows this
and then uses it against him and says i
mean we can we can go in there right now
right when miles meets him later on he's
like we can go in there right now and i
can just tell them everything that's
going on
miles responses no fine like i'll meet
with you the same place as last time and
so when the two of them end up meeting
up together
miles shows up and says this is not
gonna happen you're like i'll tell my
parents if i need to but here's what's
gonna go on you're gonna leave town
right like you are really a bad person
you're every bit as bad as my dad said
you were right like you really don't
care about anybody but yourself like you
don't come near me
you don't come near my parents right now
this was important for miles this was a
hugely
important moment for miles morales and
the reason why is because for his
character
the way he was originally written he
wasn't necessarily a people pleaser but
he had this desire
to connect with his uncle aaron and the
fact that he was able to connect to a
degree
even when he was younger and he spent
time with him knowing that he wasn't
necessarily supposed to
you know in this moment right now
spending time with his uncle aaron and
trying to
to get to you know get to know him on a
more personal level
is compounded and made difficult by the
fact that aaron really is a bad guy and
so coming to him with miles morales
being
largely a a character who lacked a lot
of confidence
in himself right he locked confidence in
himself what he was capable of and what
he could achieve
to in turn come along and to go against
someone
somebody like the prowler who despite
not having the powers of spider-man
is wildly capable of going toe-to-toe
with one uh is you know he's basically
saying like you're gonna leave here
right like you're gonna leave this town
you're never gonna talk to me or my
parents again
you know and and it's it's one of these
things where where power is like fine
like if you want to play
with the big boys then you got to be
ready and then he in turn attacks miles
morales and this is not
easy fight for miles right using a
combination of all of his gadgetry his
sonics
all those things at his disposal he's
able to kind of get the get the upper
hand
on miles but one of the important things
here is that miles starts to gain more
confidence in his abilities
and begins to use his powers in the way
that he's supposed to right making
himself invisible using
you know using a sneak attack using
subtlety different things like that and
that's one of the important things to
understand
is that when it comes to someone like
miles what he lacks an experience he
makes up for in powers that peter parker
simply just didn't have
peter parker did not have a venom blast
he could not make himself invisible
right and so
you know with with miles the fact that
he's still learning how to fight this
actually bends itself to his favor right
instead of being something that can just
enhance his existing abilities it can
help him compensate for his lack of
experience right
making himself invisible and then coming
back around again and so he's able to to
kind of get the upper hand on aaron and
actually ends up damaging one of his
gloves right one of his power gloves and
when that happens of course the fight
ends up leading down into the street
where basically there's almost like this
massive wreck or
this this city bus you know kind of
topples over when aaron ends up blasting
it right with his gloves and that's
really when miles begins to get the
bigger picture that aaron really doesn't
care about anybody but himself that he
really is
a tried and true villain and this is
also significant because one of the
biggest issues that miles had is he had
this desire to inherently see the good
in everybody and while that's not
necessarily a bad thing
that kind of naivety can really cause
you problems later on down the line
right the belief that people are
inherently good and if they end up doing
bad things it's because they were in a
rough spot but they want to become good
people that can cost lives
and that's what miles is learning here
that aaron isn't a guy who was just down
on his luck and ended up in a bad spot
and there's a way to reach him and turn
him back into a good guy he's just a bad
person and the fact that he's willing to
like
endanger the lives of a busload of
people in order to
to to get the upper hand in a fight
against miles morales really shows the
kind of person that he is
and so at that point miles morales
starts cutting loose right he starts
letting loose and it's just like
fun like like if that's how we're gonna
fight then let's fight this is gonna be
a knock down dragon fight he uses his
venom blast starts you know starts
literally hitting aaron from every
direction and getting the upper hand the
problem with this is that in a split
second aaron gets the upper hand on
on miles and goes to attack him and
seemingly does it with the intention of
killing him the problem with this
is the previous attack by miles that
damaged his glove ends up coming home to
roost when the whole thing
explodes right it's like a bomb going
off and when that happens
it kills aaron right it looks like it
kills aaron and so it's just kind of
like the last little word
that miles gets here from aaron is like
look at that
right you're just like me you don't care
who you kill
as long as you come out on top it's just
this crushing response
to miles effectively getting his uncle
killed or seemingly getting his uncle
killed
make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering spider-man but
here's something that i want to throw
out there real quick
right because i know some people are
gonna ask the question rob didn't you
cover this already
what i covered was spider-man 2. uh
here's the important thing about this
right spider-man is probably one of the
most
important spider-man stories i'd say of
the last 15 years
and the reason why is because this is
the story where peter
parker first met miles morales right so
um one of the things we've talked about
here
over the course of really some of the
miles morales videos that we've done
and a lot of the peter parker videos
that we did is we kind of talked about
the nature of the ultimate universe
right so if you guys are familiar with
this we just finished the video
yesterday where we talked about that the
miles morales one right so just kind of
bear with me right we'll probably have
some new people to the channel i know
you guys
kind of like to get directly into it but
bear with me for a second while i kind
of
kind of reiterate this uh for for the
people who are new here right who are
new to marvel comics um
in marvel you have a great big huge
multiverse right technically the marvel
cinematic universe is considered part of
the multiverse that makes up
all of marvel comics uh we know that for
a couple different reasons one because
it actually has a numerical designation
among the marvel multiverse and two
because there's comics based on it right
so that kind of brings it closer in line
with being part of the marvel multiverse
but where you had marvel comics as it
was originally launched in the 1960s
right with the fantastic four number one
and so on and so forth that's referred
to
as earth-616 right also known as the
main marvel universe what we got in in
the year 2000 was the creation of the
ultimate universe
and this was an answer to the question
what would it look like if at that point
in time in the year 2000
superheroes had just basically popped up
right they just kind of emerged for the
very first time uh what would that what
would those superheroes look like how
would they function how would all that
stuff work
uh and that's basically where you got
peter parker in the ultimate universe
now ultimate spider-man was
exceedingly popular right it was hugely
popular because in a lot of ways it was
kind of an indirect reboot right marvel
didn't really
reboot everything with the main marvel
universe spider-man they just gave us a
new one and people loved it right people
absolutely loved it but what you saw was
a story where basically peter parker
died right peter parker spider-man was
killed and it might behoove us to go
back and cover that event right cover
cataclysm and the death of of peter
parker right it might behoove us to do
that
just because you know we're kind of
doing a lot of this stuff because the
new spider-man game is coming out for
the playstation uh but the idea is that
when that version of peter parker died
uh we ended up getting miles morales in
his place and when miles morales first
showed up there was a lot of naysayers
there were a lot of people who were just
kind of like miles morales sucks he's
not really spider-man he's not really
peter parker that kind of a thing
because it kind of came from a couple
different places a lot of fans were
latched on to the idea of peter parker
even when they were reading him before
the ultimate universe was launched right
so all they really got was just another
alternate reality version of peter
and they loved it a lot of people grew
attached to peter parker spider-man in
the ultimate universe when that was
their first place to start
in marvel comics but by whatever manner
and whatever means a lot of people just
didn't want to see things change
this story is in a lot of ways kind of
brian michael bendis
snubbing people who were naysayers of
miles morales right uh people who were
just like this this character's not
going to last or anything like that
it was kind of been just being like no
he will like he's going to be around for
a long time
and that's really where this comes from
and i tell you that because it's
important that you understand the
historical context of this story as we
get into it so you can understand
why this story is considered to be so
important with all that out of the way
let us jump to the main story itself uh
and so what we end up getting here is
picking up in the main marvel universe
or 616 with peter parker spider-man and
is peter parker just kind of doing the
stuff that peter parker does
right like swinging around coming across
some criminals some guys who are doing
some things they're not supposed
to do but here's the funny thing about
this because of the fact that this story
was written
as a way to kind of tie into or kind of
bring together the ultimate universe and
the main marvel universe this story was
written in such a way to where it was
designed to treat people
as if they're aware of who spider-man is
but they don't really know much about
him right they don't really know a whole
lot about the character right so it's
kind of reiterating the nature of peter
parker and that's one of the things that
you see
in marvel comics there are certain
characters out there who people know who
they are right people know who iron man
is now
people know who spider-man is people
know who wolverine is but
knowing of knowing who the character is
and understanding the history and the
context of the character
are two distinctly different things you
know so a lot of people know who iron
man is
but i doubt they really know anything
about the mandarin or i doubt they know
about stories like demon in a bottle and
why it's so important
uh what is it the five nightmares run by
matt fraction different things like that
right arno stark kieran gillen's run a
lot of people probably aren't really
familiar with that so uh the idea is
that we're just kind of giving peter
parker in terms of how peter parker
operates but just to say kind of amusing
to himself about how much he loves new
york city and the fact that new york
city is kind of like a thinking
breathing entity
right that there are so many facets to
this city you've got people who have
their nose to the ground and they're
just grinding day in and day out just
trying to make it by you've got people
who are just super high up in their
ivory ivory towers you know the tony
starks the reed richards who don't
really have to worry about small time
things right but you kind of have
everybody who falls in between and
there's just
so many different varying types of
people in the city of new york that is
just
so unique in that way what it also has
are criminals
[Laughter]
there's criminals in new york city and
spider-man goes to visit some and
he basically wallops them one or two
times shows them what for and then of
course you know ends up pulling over the
vehicle you know which is their getaway
car
and as soon as he's there he's met by
the arrival of the cops right and the
cops are just like take off your mask
show us your face you know
that kind of a thing now the truth about
this is i was never really part and
parcel to this kind of depiction of
spider-man of peter parker and the
reason why
is because you have had stories over the
years where jay jonah jameson and the
daily bugle have kind of managed to sort
of turn
you know the the idea of spider-man into
something where he can't really be
trusted he's a menace but the the long
and short of it is that over the years
spider-man was largely trusted by
society right you know your friendly
neighborhood spider-man he was the good
guy right he was largely trusted in that
way
there have been times where it's waxed
and waned but in this instance i kind of
feel like it should have been one of
those things where it's like thanks
spider-man you know and
that's that's kind of it right now the
fact that the cops show up here and he's
behind the behind the wheel of a getaway
car
might give him a little reason to be
suss right but i don't know why i say
that all the time mariah started saying
sus and now i say it all the time right
like
suss it's a weird word but anyway uh
once he takes off and he kind of you
know goes and does his thing he ends up
fighting this building you know
this kind of uh this this office
building basically where the the
the roof has been shattered right the
glass has been shattered and he's kind
of like that's a little weird now of
course he ends up
being drawn to that location because of
a giant bright light almost kind of an
explosion of sorts and of course once he
gets there like the whole place
kind of seems to be tarnished right and
there's just this white light or this
bright light emanating from it all now
as he gets in there and as he starts
investigating his initial thought is
this energy source is a little weird now
this story was released about a year
after
spider-man big time and for those of you
guys who aren't really familiar if you
ever wanted to get into spider-man i
always suggest people start with big
time we have that that whole series
covered on my channel and big time was
the start of dan slots run
you had spider-man and you had mary jane
who were like married and all that kind
of stuff and then you got one more day
then you got brand new day where marvel
basically nullified it all uh because
that was just so poorly received
big time was kind of marvel's huge shift
with peter parker right focusing on like
an all-new age for peter parker
spider-man uh but that's kind of a good
place to start right because dan slott's
run begins with that and runs
all the way up through secret wars and
after secret wars into clone conspiracy
right so
it's a it's like a 10 almost 15 year
long run of spider-man it's
very very lengthy but i think it's also
incredibly
good i think it's an amazing run on
spider-man but the whole idea behind
this
is that uh that this takes place about a
year after that now the reason why i
mention that is because
i'm not entirely partial partial to how
this is handled by bendis right vendis
is notorious
for writing a character and then
pretending like nothing anybody did ever
happened right and it's just like the
only things that matter with this
character is what i'm doing here and
ignoring continuity in its entirety now
whether it's kind of business is always
that way i'm not 100 sure i wasn't
really reading vendors back when he was
part of
uh of event publications with jimmy
palmiotti and joe casada i wasn't really
reading him back then
i only really got familiar with brian
michael bendis once he actually came in
the main marvel itself and was writing
like new avengers right uh and new
avengers was a wholly new thing so he
could kind of get away with that uh
it's something that i think maybe a
result of his like his huge amount of
popularity and it's kind of like i'm
bendis
i can do whatever in the heck i want i
don't know if that's really the case or
not but the reason why that matters is
because during spider-man big time
peter parker's intelligence had always
kind of been downplayed by marvel comics
right they never really
kind of elevated peter parker to being
on par with like reed richards or tony
stark you always kind of knew he was
but they never really did any of that
for him instead what you end up getting
here
is peter parker kind of looking at this
and just being like man this is weird
he's like it's not it's not you know
anything alien in nature uh maybe i
should get a hold of like tony stark or
reed richards or something like that
during big time one of the big things
that dan slot did was focus on the
intelligence of peter parker and in
being like peter parker's actually
pretty daggone smart and he doesn't
always need reed richards or tony stark
to solve a problem on his own that was
kind of solidified in a story where
there was like a bomb that was going to
go off and nobody else could defuse it
and peter parker was the one who did
right so he was kind of elevating his
intelligence up and basically telling
the reader base hey peter parker's not
as dumb as he's being made out to be you
know he's not just a spider-man right
he's a super intelligent guy let's start
treating him that way so not entirely
partial on how this works but as he
starts navigating this room he starts to
realize
all this stuff belongs to mysterio right
all these things belong to him and
that's what mysterio tries to sneak up
behind peter and attack him and of
course peter parker's spider-sense goes
off and he basically ends up you know
kind of kind of being aware that he's
about to be attacked and
manages to dodge out of the way now with
mysterio and one thing that a lot of you
guys are probably aware of after having
seen spider-man far from home mysterio
is a legitimate credible threat to peter
parker
right he's probably one of peter
parker's most dangerous villains his
ability to cast delusions to basically
trick peter parker and his spider sense
it can be pretty difficult to overcome
mysterio and that's one of the reasons
why you have you know peter parker kind
of saying here like i've got to get this
guy down
as fast as i can because this guy is a
real and serious threat
the other part of this is that mysterio
keeps rambling on about how like peter
parker's ruining things and he's kind of
destroying things and and so on and so
forth and then he goes as far as to say
like you have no idea what you're
dealing with right you have no idea what
i'm capable of uh i missed out when you
died the first time
i'm not going to miss out this time
right so right off the bat our cue is
that this is some kind of ability
for from mysterio to actually look
through into the ultimate universe where
that version of peter parker died and
mysterio wants to be
in that universe where peter parker
doesn't exist right his main nemesis the
person that always foiled his plans he's
just trying to find a way to escape and
so what you end up getting here is is
peter just kind of looking at this and
saying like like what is this thing
right is this some kind of a power
generator or whatever this is it's weird
that this is here but like i can call
people they can basically break this
down and take this thing apart so we
don't really have to worry about it
right while peter parker
doesn't really know what's going on with
this device he knows enough about
mysterio to know it's probably not a
good thing
right like when super villains start
doing weird things you don't understand
you can usually just assume it's bad and
you're not usually wrong in doing that
it's a good rule of thumb to have but of
course in his desperation mysterio ends
up grabbing
uh grabbing a handgun and firing it off
and then missing peter parker and
hitting his device and when that happens
he's yanked through right peter is
seemingly yanked through into basically
the ultimate universe
and this is the first time one of the
reasons why this is so big this is the
very very
first time in the history of marvel
comics that a character from the main
marvel universe
crossed over into the ultimate universe
right this was a huge deal now the
ultimate universe
it exists now in marvel comics but it's
nowhere near as a big deal as it was
back in like the early to mid 2000s
right at around the time and even really
in the early 2010s when this story was
written uh this is when the ultimate
universe was really kind of at its prime
depending on you know what you were
reading there was a lot of fall off
after the death of peter parker you know
we can't really you know that's just an
absolute thing we can't really argue
that point but the death of peter parker
in the ultimate universe actually made
headlines right he made national news
headlines and so
because that there was a lot of interest
in the ultimate universe and so it was
really a great time to capitalize on
that right to kind of give us this story
but this is a big deal when this first
happened and so as peter parker's there
he's like okay
this is weird like it's suddenly daytime
uh i don't know what that great big huge
building is over there that's the
triskelion that great big huge
tower looking thing off in the water uh
you guys probably recognize the
triskelion from
uh captain america the winter soldier
that's where this comes from that's why
we say the marvel cinematic universe is
a combination of the ultimate universe
uh the main marvel universe in earth 98
where the heroes age in real time uh
it's kind of a combination of those
three things but he ends up traveling
back to the building
where uh where you had you know the
whole um
mysterious base of operations and
everything popping off and uh and
he basically ends up breaking into the
place only to find out that it's
occupied with some girl in a towel and
he's like
my bad it basically bails out right ends
up taking off
from there he actually ends up rescuing
a guy who's you know kind of being uh
being beat up a little bit he takes out
the two of the two people who are
beating this dude up and he basically
says he was just playing pool and then
suddenly they jumped him but the fact
that he's wearing a peter parser a peter
parker costume wearing a spider-man
costume does not go unnoticed by this
guy and he's like look i appreciate you
saving me but like it's
really in bad taste for you to wear that
costume right now what's more so than
that he's like you know we all need
heroes but that was peter parker's
costume and that's one of the big things
to know when peter parker died and
and even peter parker was spider-man his
identity was known right
when all that popped off his identity
was known to the world people were like
the world needs to know that this is the
kid who tried to save everybody who died
a hero
that's why the death of peter parker was
so massive in the ultimate universe
right like imagine for example
that like in the main marvel universe in
marvel comics that iron man dies
and it's this great big huge event that
crosses over
every single comic that they have right
it's like the death of iron man you know
the incredible hulk tie-in and the
captain america tie-in and all that kind
of stuff right like everything
ties into just the fact that iron man
died and how everybody's coping with it
that's what the death of peter parker
was
it was just huge it was massive because
spider-man
had never actually been killed off in
marvel comics with no intention of
bringing him back
right that's just never happened before
right i mean movement kind of tried it
with the clone saga but like that was
never gonna happen uh with the ultimate
universe it's the way it is peter
parker's been dead
you know he's like the the peter parker
spiderman concept is dead and miles
morales have taken it over and has been
that way ever since so it was kind of a
big deal it was a huge deal when it
happened but this guy that the fact that
this guy reveals that they know who
peter parker is
really throws like the main marvel
universe peter parker off because
his identity is something that he keeps
insanely close
guarded right now in the in in civil war
he revealed it to the world just as kind
of a proof of the fact that he trusted
iron man superhero registration but of
course
as we saw in the aftermath of that brand
new day that doctor strange came along
and just
magicked everybody's memory of peter
parker's identity out of their heads
right he's just like you magic and then
nobody remembered that peter parker was
spider-man and that was essentially it
right
that was basically it that's probably
what they're going to end up doing in
spider-man 3 the movie
but the the whole point behind this is
that this throws peter parker for a loop
because he's kind of like okay
that's crazy like wherever it is they're
referring to me in the third person
so one this guy doesn't know who i am
but he knows who peter parker is so that
means there was a peter parker here in
this place
what in the world is going on right now
and so what ends up happening is he's
ultimately met by the arrival of miles
morales and miles morales pops up and
he's just like
no way right because to the eyes of
miles morales this is the ultimate
universe version of peter parker it's
like peter parker has come back
that's what kind of blew things off
right that's what drive that's what
makes miles morales kind of go nuts here
okay so we are picking back up again
with uh spider-man part two and this
week we're going to kind of run through
a whole bunch of spider-man related
content mostly because of the fact that
the new spider-man game is coming out we
kind of want to be done in time for all
that stuff
but um and this one we pick up with part
two right now again for those of you
guys who are just joining us here
spider-man is the first time that peter
parker from the main marvel universe
meets miles morales the new spider-man
in the ultimate universe right this is a
big deal when it first came out now we
ended up having this happening by way of
the fact that
uh mysterio had basically managed to
create some kind of interdimensional
portal and the result was that when
peter parker came upon it and ended up
fighting mysterio peter parker ended up
being thrown through
it was kind of sucked through more than
anything else but peter parker passed
through it ended up in the ultimate
universe what this does is it wakes up
with mysterio
in the aftermath of that now as soon as
mysterio comes to his immediate response
is really bro he's incredibly pissed off
right because he's just like this is the
worst
thing now it's not like super
complicated or anything that's one of
the the great things about brian michael
bendis when he was writing really
ultimate spider-man and miles morales
spider-man i always say business is
better when he's writing kids or
teenagers when it comes to adults he's
not that good but with kids or teenagers
he's amazing right so writing miles
morales he was super good at it but the
idea behind this is that from mysterio's
perspective
he does not want to run into another
situation where peter parker
exists that him basically stumbling
across the ultimate universe was a
universe where peter parker spider-man
didn't really exist peter parker had
never heard of mysterio and so with
you know him you know really presuming
that miles morales that he knew miles
existed there miles could be somebody he
could overcome pretty
pretty quickly right because by and
large when it comes to marvel comics
villains from the from the main marvel
universe are usually more powerful from
villain
than villains from the ultimate universe
and even main characters themselves
even somebody like the phoenix force or
like thor or loki they're really
powerful characters in relation to their
to their ultimate universe counterparts
because the ultimate universe was
designed to be more toned down and
realistic
even in the realm of comic books if
you're writing a character and really a
series of stories that exist
as close as you can get to the real
world you probably don't want to really
see these wild flights of fantasy when
it comes to ridiculous level of
levels of power right like the marquee
of death different things like that but
the whole idea here is that what you end
up having is mysterio who basically
kind of brings out this kind of avatar
and this is basically a version of
himself kind of a robotic version of
himself that can go into the ultimate
universe instead right because if you're
mysterio you don't want to get yourself
killed going into the ultimate universe
you send a robot in your place and so
switching over to peter and miles this
is one of the interesting things here
albeit a little strange and the reason
why is because
initially peter doesn't know what to
make of miles and miles doesn't know
what to make of peter right he's like
what in the world's going on
and peter hasn't figured out that he's
in the ultimate universe because he
doesn't know what the ultimate
universe is he just knows he's in some
other place right and seemingly picking
up pretty quickly on the fact that he's
in some kind of an alternate dimension
and so because of this there's a you
know kind of fight that starts to break
out between peter and miles because
peter's like okay you're freaking me out
right because they keep going back and
forth right peter's like what's the deal
here
miles is like you tell me and peter's
like is it a clone thing and he's like
what's a clone thing it's like you tell
me it's like i thought this was some
kind of nick fury test is it a nick fury
test and miles is like you tell me and
it's like you're just kind of going back
and forth
right so peter gets frustrated gets a
little uh gets a little test and
uh ends up attacking miles right ends up
going after miles but miles for his part
immediately dodges spider-man's webbing
right and so from there
what you end up getting is this really
interesting situation where miles is
able to bob and weave
and duck all of spider-man's attacks and
then counter proportionally now
this is where things get a little wonky
right this is where things get a little
you know i don't know how i feel about
that right because keep in mind miles
has not been formally trained by anybody
at shield yet right
in anybody in the triskelion by nick
fury or any of those guys and so he is
still in a lot of ways
flying by the seat of his pants and so
the fact that we're kind of getting this
version of miles who over his time in
being spider-man is able to go
toe-to-toe with peter parker who's been
playing
this role for a very long time and not
only go toe-to-toe managed to dodge his
attacks and then shock him
is a little bit stunning here but no pun
intended it's a little bit stunning here
but the funny thing about this too is we
can also kind of play into it into it
from peter's perspective that peter is
not fighting to like beat the crap out
of miles right he's not looking to like
overcome miles he's looking to kind of
subdue him
if anything else right probably web him
up or something like that if peter were
fighting miles in the same vein that he
was fighting somebody like rino or like
dr
octopus or somebody like that the fight
probably would have gone a much
different way and it would have been
over much much faster the reality is
which way this fight would have gone
depends on which character you like more
that's basically what it is right if
you're a fan of miles you're like of
course miles could overcome peter parker
if you don't believe me just ask me and
i'll tell you but if you're a fan of
peter parker it's the exact same thing
right it's like no peter parker
definitely could have gotten the upper
hand on miles right i mean i know
because i'm right right i mean
that's kind of how we as comic book fans
get we need no other evidence than our
own opinion
and that's basically it now the funny
thing is miles actually goes to take the
mask
off peter which miles should know by now
is kind of a no-no that's just something
that you don't do
and that leads to peter basically
reacting you know waking up and then
kicking miles off the ledge of the
building right and then from there
peter's like dude i think i just killed
this kid
i think i just did this kid in uh i do
not need that on my conscience right i
do not need this
on my conscience now unbeknownst to him
of course miles has initiated his
invisibility
power but nonetheless peter's just kind
of like uh okay i think i killed this
kid this is this is the problem
we gotta find this kid right and then
miles pops back up gets the upper hand
on peter kicks him and then of course
peter ends up kind of
spinning some webbing out and then from
there he shoots his webbing into mile's
mask and yanks his mask off right and
that's what he's kind of like all right
it's time for you to come clean right
like how are you spider-man what's going
on here like like give me all the skinny
give me all the information now the
response of miles is you have to give me
my mask back right like anybody out here
could see that i'm spider-man and i have
to keep my family
and my identity protected like give me
my mask back now you would expect peter
to respond and say yeah i kind of
understand where you're coming from
that's kind of my thing too
but desperate times call for desperate
measures and peter needs information the
problem with this
is he didn't really understand why miles
got the upper hand on him the first time
and so he didn't really even think about
the venom blast this time which miles
uses
channels it into the into the webbing
and then takes out peter it's genius
and that was one of the cool things that
made miles so interesting in the early
comics is when you were reading his
character you could actually watch him
become a biter a better spider-man
as you were reading the comic and so
with every single story arc that you
read
he was a better version of spider-man at
the end of that story than he was before
he started the story but it was really
really cool but with regards to peter
what you end up getting here
is miles basically using peter's web
shooters right to kind of swing them
you know down to down to the ground and
they kind of get them onto a roof and
they get them to safety
and when they collapse right he ends up
taking the mask off peter and he
realizes oh my god this is peter parker
now for him he doesn't know this is
peter from the marvel universe from the
main marvel universe right he thinks
it's like peter parker returned from his
universe so he's like i have no idea
what i do here right and that's when he
kind of looks over to the triskelion and
peter parker's taken to the shield
headquarters right from there he meets
with nick fury now most of the guys who
read the ultimate universe
know two things about nick fury the
first one is that he was based on samuel
jackson right and in fact samuel jackson
actually threatened to sue marvel but
they ended up letting him play the role
of nick fury in the mcu so the lawsuit
never happened
that's why we got samuel jackson nick
fury but the other thing about this is
that nick fury is highly skeptical right
he is a
super suspicious guy and so when he
starts asking questions when he starts
asking him like like
at least when he refers to him as peter
and peter's like like do you know me and
he's like i know the name you know and
it's that kind of a thing he start the
two of them start talking to each other
and it's kind of a cool bit of a
conversation here right because peter
even makes reference to the fact that
like i know your eye patch but it's
it's one of these little these little
tidbit things but when he asks him like
you know
are you peter parker it's like well it's
not that straightforward and it's like
okay well then give me give me an answer
give me this one hypothetical answer
that you have and peter basically
reiterates his whole fight with mysterio
then passing through the portal and then
ending up here and all that kind of
stuff and nick fury's kind of like huh
okay i mean i could probably buy that
story it's so far-fetched it might just
be true right
it's just it's one of those things so he
just kind of ends up giving peter
credibility here now the reality of this
is that bendis does this
just for the sake of keeping the story
moving forward under any other comic in
the ultimate universe nick fury would be
like no
i'm not buying that you're gonna stay in
this cell until you tell me what's
actually going on
and he would legitimately leave him
there nick free would have done that if
you if you if you sat down if this
happened in the ultimates and it was
anybody else besides spider-man if it
was ultimates or
like the ultimate fantastic four or the
ultimate x-men nick fury would be like
no
man i'm not buying that that nonsense
that crazy malarkey not buying into that
any of that stuff right so he would just
leave him there but
vendis does this for the sake of keeping
the story moving forward what he ends up
doing is basically handing peter over to
miles and say okay it's your all's job
to go do your own thing right you're
all's job to get this whole thing sorted
out and find out what's going on and so
what peter does
is by virtue of what nick fury told him
the way that miles is acting that kind
of thing he starts to put two and two
together and so what he does is he
really kind of asks the big question
like tell me kid
in this universe is peter parker dead
right is peter parker not alive here
anymore and that's what's kind of nuts
is because before miles can really give
him an answer and explain everything
both of them are shot through the
helicopter
by this avatar of mysterio and in turn
miles basically
saves both of them and then kind of
takes both guys or really takes him and
the pilot down to their safety
right but basically mysterio's here and
starts launching his attack against uh
against peter and miles so this is when
we go from
miles morales meeting peter parker to
miles fighting peter to miles and peter
teaming up
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with spider-man
uh almost spider-man 2 with spider-man
we're picking back up with miles morales
and peter parker now this is kind of a
three-pronged event right like the first
time
in the first issue they met and the
second issue they fought and this one
they team up
so it's kind of cool a cool bit of
storytelling here right but in the
instance where they had initially
fought each other and things had kind of
popped off and they were sort of coming
to
coming to terms and you know with
regards to this reality they're suddenly
met by this this avatar of mysterio now
again this is kind of the
robot slash you know really just
straight robot that mysterio is using
he is in the main marvel universe but
he's piloting this and it's moving
around in the ultimate universe right
and so because of that as soon as it
takes down the helicopter that peter
parker and
miles morales were in the two of them
start to team up to fight up mysterio
the problem with this is that that miles
morales has never really fought anybody
like mysterio before and even mysterio
as he exists in the main marvel universe
doesn't really exist the same way in the
ultimate universe
to kind of give you guys some
perspective of the big differences
between these two things because i
believe by this point doctor strange is
dead
um there came a point in the ultimate
universe where doctor strange fought
dormammu and in the main marvel universe
doctor strain has fought dormammu
a multitude of times and won pretty much
every single time in the ultimate
universe he fights him once and dies
it's nuts like he's he's painfully
outclassed in comparison to the power
that dormammu has he kills him with a
quickness and that's basically it but
it happens so incredibly fast because
you're talking about mysterio
who still maintains his ability to
create illusions despite using a kind of
avatar form
you end up having peter parker who picks
up on what's going on now
it took him a moment to realize it
because he's like something weird is
going on right it's a more more
powerful strain of the illusion that he
normally uses but what he ends up doing
is conjuring
all of spider-man's villains and the the
things that miles morales fears the most
right so basically their greatest fears
between the two of them and with this
happening you really only ever see the
scorpion from the ultimate universe you
see uncle aaron the prowler from the
ultimate universe and omega red from the
ultimate universe but you only really
see those because those the only really
the villains that miles morales has
fought so far for peter parker
it's it's a whole host of stuff right
it's a whole host of things green goblin
and dr octopus and all that stuff but
that's what makes it so bonkers is
because of the fact
that miles doesn't really know how to
navigate this now this kind of illusion
that mysterio creates that's one of the
big things to understand his illusions
can be tangible if they're powerful
enough
they can be tangible and that's one of
the big differences is that in the early
days if i remember correctly in the
early days his illusions were more or
less intangible right so he could trick
you into believing you were somewhere
but he couldn't really make things
interact with you
in this instance he can and it's really
kind of been that way for a number of
years
in marvel comics but mysterio uses his
powers to quite literally have these
guys
attack uh miles morales and spider-man
and peter parker right so it's like
venom and it's carnage it's all these
guys and this is incredibly dangerous
because these are forces that miles
isn't used to facing off against but
this is one of the big differences here
is that miles hasn't really faced off
against mysterio before
but at the same time this kind of magic
doesn't necessarily see exist
inside the ultimate universe now this
may seem like it would naturally work
against miles morales
he's basically being exposed to
something that he hasn't really seen
before and wouldn't really know how to
navigate those waters but instead of
doing what peter parker seems to be
doing here which is kind of overthinking
it to a degree
instead miles actually manages to get
the upper hand and basically
incapacitate mysterio temporarily you
know if for no other reason than to
basically take down his avatar form and
then essentially destroy it right like
destroy that body because miles picks up
on the fact this is the reason why it's
happening now
again this is one of those instances in
the ultimate spider-man comics where
people were a little finicky they were
like
i mean i have a hard time believing that
miles would be able to pick up on this
and peter parker couldn't you're talking
about two characters from two different
realities who navigate waters
differently they were when this when the
story first came out there was one group
of people who looked at this and said
okay
the only reason miles is able to figure
this out on his own is because business
is writing it and bendis
is pushing miles and does it really
wants him to be like the new ultimate
universe spider-man
and of what use would his character be
if he didn't have some kind of
caveat over peter parker from you know
peter parker in general right even from
the main marvel universe it's one of
these interesting concepts one of these
interesting quagmires but again you know
with with regards to mysterio
he's one of these villains where by all
standards of measurement he would have
gotten the upper hand on miles morales
because what makes mysterio's uh you
know his his powers
so incredibly potent is he's much like
mastermind or somebody like charles
xavier not in so much as the powers he
possesses he's just an illusionist right
he doesn't really have telepathy or
anything like that
but much like those guys his powers can
totally envelope you and convince you
that you're somewhere that you're not
right
mysterio gets his hands on you he can
convince you that you're a world away
you know and
and you're in you know some pirate land
and you're fighting against pirates or
something like that
you know the whether or not you're able
to actually pick up on that are two
distinctly different things right
creating that illusion if you're of
sound mind you'll immediately know that
something's off right
regardless when everything kind of pops
off peter parker actually ends up taking
off he doesn't leave the universe he
just goes to explore it and what you end
up having are the ultimates who arrive
here on the scene with miles morales now
one of the big things that goes on here
is again
because these characters were designed
to be a lot more toned down than the
versions that we saw in the ultimate
universe
that tony stark doesn't really know how
to navigate this this technology right
like in the main marvel universe he
would have picked it up right off the
bat and just been like okay so here's
what's going on with this
instead in the ultimate universe his
intelligence is a little more grounded
right so it's not as though he's just
wildly out there as intelligent as a
story needs him to be instead it's a
little more grounded here
so he recognized it in so far as this an
exceedingly
you know advanced form of technology and
that it's an avatar that's basically
being used by you know this mysterio guy
to control you know control this this
avatar version from someplace else but
in terms of being able to reverse
engineer it almost instantaneously
that doesn't happen here right that
doesn't really take place here now for
miles part
of course he ends up asking nick fury
where'd the other spider-man go and
fewer's responses he went out there to
explore things and that's the nature
of this right when you're when you're
someone like spider-man and you face off
against mysterio and you've gone through
his illusions so many times
the biggest struggle he has here is
trying to figure out whether any of this
is real or false
that's the biggest struggle he has at
the moment because you got to kind of
think of this from peter's perspective
he was in his own universe he was facing
off against mysterio found himself
yanked through a portal
ended up in this new reality where he's
dead there's a new spider-man that took
his place
uh and that there's a there's a nick
fury there you know who seemingly
allowed the two of them to team up and
then mysterio's avatar appears he ends
up facing off against all of his
villains even though they're illusions
and then of course miles morales ends up
destroying that
avatar and now peter's basically
exploring in his mind all of this could
be the illusion
and that's the truth of the thing right
that's the truth of the thing here when
you're facing off against mysterio
this could all be illusion it's entirely
possible that bendis could have ended
this story and it was all just one great
huge illusion created by by a mysterio
and it would work
it would be believable because he's done
it before right that's the advancement
of mysterio's illusions is that it just
it screws with your head
so incredibly badly but as we know peter
parker
is actually in the ultimate universe and
so he basically starts tracking
different things down right he goes to
the place that would have been his
apartment he ends up finding a corner
store he asked them like how long has it
been here she's like i don't know how
long have you worked here i've worked
here two years you know and he's like
okay so there was never an apartment
building here you know like there like
there was never an apartment here and so
basically he never stayed here
the other thing that ends up happening
after he you know beats up some guy who
runs into the place and robs it is he
asks her for you know for a tablet that
can help him access the internet and
when he does he finds an article
that the spider-man in this universe
really did die here and that it really
that everybody really knew
that he was peter parker that he was a
high school student from queens and so
it's one of these things where it's kind
of like i really am in a universe where
i'm dead
the other part of that is of course she
has this little necklace around her neck
and of course is her way of paying
respects to peter parker as spider-man
and then he's like
you need to tell me exactly what
happened to peter parker in this
universe and so what we end up doing is
we basically end up picking up uh you
know some period of time later with aunt
may and with gwen stacy from the
ultimate universe and peter parker
shows up on their doorstep right like
literally just shows up there
and this is one of the most amazing
things here it's one of the most amazing
moments because this is peter parker
coming to grips with gwen stacy who is
still alive in this universe and aunt
may and having to face the fact that in
their mind
he's dead and so it's kind of like wow
like this is one of those things it's a
hyper emotional story if you're a peter
parker fan right
it's kind of nuts it's peter parker
re-encountering
uh aunt may and gwen stacy it's kind of
nuts
okay we're picking back up again with uh
spider-man which is the conclusion of
the story where peter parker meets miles
morales for the very very first time
right peter parker from the main marvel
universe
meets the ultimate spider-man miles
morales and the whole idea behind this
is that we pick up with peter parker
following his kind of encounter
alongside uh miles with mysterio who use
basically use the kind of robot version
of himself to move into the ultimate
universe or to travel to the ultimate
universe
uh peter parker has essentially traveled
to meet uh the ultimate universe's
version
of gwen stacy and mary jane watson now
keep in mind the last time they saw
spider-man
it was their version of peter parker and
he died and largely there was just kind
of the grieving process that went into
it now
one of the things that we talked about
in the early miles morales comics that
we did
is that there did come a point when
miles took on the spider-man costume
and was met by aunt may and and gwen
stacy and they were kind of like look if
you're gonna do this
understand that you're living up to a
legacy much bigger than yourself right
you don't just simply put on the
spider-man costume and do your thing
you're living up to the legacy that my
nephew created uh and you stand
for everything he stood for so this is
not a thing to take lightly right so it
was kind of
initially they were against it but it's
one of these things we're just kind of
like okay you know we can sort of get on
board once they realize the character
of miles morales and what he had to
offer but the problem with this is that
when peter shows up he's wearing the
original spider-man costume and as soon
as aunt may sees this she gets pissed
right because he basically showed his
face and her thought is as some kind of
a
some kind of a joke right gwen stacy
shows up and starts kicking the crap
out of out of peter parker thinking that
he's pulling a stunt too and it's not
until
miles shows up and says no no no it's
really actually peter right it's not
somebody pulling a pulling a trick or
something like that not somebody being a
jerk i don't really know of a reasonable
human being that would show up on the
doorstep
of a woman and like basically two chicks
who lost
somebody close to them dressed as that
person right i mean if somebody were to
do that i would wholly like i would
stand by
and just watch them get the crap kicked
out of them i'd record it and then just
be like yeah man
this guy kind of had it coming like
that'd be my response
i'd be like yeah man like they were kind
of a dick they sort of had this comment
right nobody do anything
let them get their just desserts but uh
this is actually peter right this is
actually peter parker here and when
miles comes to his rescue that's when
aunt may
and gwen stacy basically start to listen
right and peter's initial response is
like like i thought initially i died i
thought something happened like i didn't
really know what was going on how i
ended up here you know i've only
recently been putting the pieces
together
i never should have come here right i
never should have come here to this
place you know i'm sorry i did this to
you and then basically
aunt may passes out right now at that
point we switch over to the ultimate
universe tony stark and nick fury right
now nick fury we've talked about before
ultimate universe iron man we've never
really had a big discussion about one of
the big things to understand here
is that ultimate iron man when he first
showed up was designed to be a more
grounded version of tony stark from the
main rover universe right so
not as intelligent because even tony in
the main marvel universe his
intelligence
even for the realm of comics
borderline's questionable right like how
could a person possibly be that smart
this version of tony is really smart but
he is a version of intelligence we would
expect to see here in the real world
right hence the nature of the ultimate
universe
kind of reflection of the real world the
way it exists now and so he's not really
able to pick up or really figure out
what mysterio what's what's going on
with mysterio's character
right how to reverse engineer the
circuitry where the signals coming from
any
all that kind of stuff the the reality
of this is there's an infinite number of
universes out there right and tony just
doesn't have the ability to trace his
signal back to its origin point now
if this were in the main marvel universe
the main marvel tony stark would have
figured it out like that but he would
have figured it out so fast because it's
what the story called for
but the idea of the ultimate universe
was to write more realistic stories
right and
really if you're talking about an
infinite number of universes there
really wouldn't be a way to trace the
signal all the way back to its origin
point because it's not like it's a rope
that leaves from the main marble
universe and all they have to do is just
follow the breadcrumbs to get to its
location it doesn't really work that way
at least not for
for anybody here and so at the end of
the day tony doesn't really have any
answers here he's like the only way for
me to really get some answers is to talk
to that alternate reality version of
spider-man to talk to peter parker it's
the only way for me to really figure out
what it is that's going on here now the
funny comment he makes is i'm surprised
that you let miles morales run around
with peter parker right i figured he
would have cracked him over the head
thrown him into a hole
uh and basically grabbed like the the
main peter and done the same thing right
kind of you know kept miles morales
under wraps so that he wouldn't really
have any idea what's going on
and then basically took peter and and
just kind of locked him up but the idea
behind this is that fury
really feels a bit of you know regret
when it comes to peter right peter was
never properly trained to become a
superhero he was never properly trained
he was never really inducted the way
that he was supposed to be he was just
kind of
allowed to do his thing and that led to
his eventual death and nick fury felt a
lot of responsibility for that that's
why when you go and you read
cataclysm there's a lot of focus put on
nick fury and the guilt he feels for the
death of peter parker because when he
could have trained him or he could have
helped him to become a better hero he
didn't
instead it was just kind of him doing
his thing and so with that guilt in mind
along with promises that he made it's
kind of like we're just gonna let them
work it out together right which is
actually the right move the best move
for nick fury to make
is is really for peter on meg when stacy
to all kind of come to terms with this
on their own and so once ame wakes up
you basically have peter like telling
stories you know to
to miles into gwen stacy them sharing
stories with him that kind of a thing
and kind of going back and forth right
and peter's coming to this realization
there's massive differences between this
reality and the one that he's from
now we as the reader know that one of
the funny things that goes on is gwen
stacy
kind of starts poking and prodding and
it's like is there a version of me
in your universe and peter's like yeah
but she's a little bit older than you
are you know she's about my age and
she's like well i mean you know like
are you dating her and peter's like i
mean not really like i'm basically
dating mary jane watson right which is
what gwen stacy calls
and then as soon as as soon as this kind
of explanation goes on that mary jane is
like a supermodel which she's not in the
ultimate universe right she's just like
a nerdy girl when it's like she's a
supermodel and all that kind of stuff
like when stacy's kind of shocked to
find out that like mary jane watson is
this hugely popular world-renowned model
and it's kind of like wow that's a
little crazy
but when she starts asking uh what about
me right like what am i then like what's
going on with me peter's like
we we should we should probably talk
about something else
i don't have the heart to tell you that
the green goblin threw you off a bridge
and i shot my my webbing at your foot
and broke your neck in the process uh
because that's basically what happened i
don't care what anybody says
she was not dead before spider-man got
there i don't care what anybody says
but uh you know it's it's kind of an
interesting thing because it's like
there are parts of his reality he
doesn't really want to divulge because
who knows how gwen stacy would react if
it was like well you're dead and i'm the
reason why then it's kind of like
get out of this house right you know i
don't want you here
but it's really kind of new to her to
learn it really fascinating for her to
learn that there's whole other worlds
and dimensions
out there now for her part aunt may is a
lot more reserved here why she's not
nearly as excited as gwen stacy is you
know she's kind of
breaking bracing herself with the idea
that it's not actually peter parker
that's like well we don't really know if
it's peter parker we don't really know
if it's him right we don't know that's
the case it could be somebody else
pretending to be him now
and in fact like it really is him we
know that miles morales believes that
gwen stacy believes it but aunt mae's
doing this because in her heart of
hearts
if she gives in to this and then it
turns out to be false she'd lose it
right like it would just be the most
crushing experience because for her
when she kind of asked peter you know
what led you to be to become this person
right when he kind of starts talking to
her about like uncle ben
uncle ben's the reason why he does this
that okaben of course is dead in his
reality
but the fact that he could have saved
uncle ben and he didn't is the reason
why he became a superhero the way that
he did and the idea that he could he
could basically help other people and in
a lot of ways a tone for his past
mistake he basically runs off the
statement with great power and then she
finishes it comes great responsibility
now it should be
must come great responsibility the fact
that this is a lesson that peter was
taught by uncle ben tells aunt may
everything she needs to know that it
really is him and that's what she kind
of gives herself over and says
we thought like like we lost you right
we lost you and we didn't even get to
say goodbye
and that's the important thing here
right that's the important thing to
understand
that's why aunt may kept herself
reserved in this part right because if
she had said like okay yeah you're
probably peter and let her whole self
believe it and then it turned out to
just be some alternate reality version
of peter who was evil or something like
that but wasn't like the this alternate
reality counterpart to the one that she
knew which is to say
a good guy who fights a good fight and
does what heroes do
then it would have broken her in her
entirety right like the the inability of
her to say goodbye the chance that she
the fact that she never got to tell
peter that she was proud of him that she
loved him right to never say like
to never be able to say i'm sorry or any
of that stuff right to basically like
confess or to to kind of get to say her
last goodbyes to him is something that's
always
haunted her having peter here this
alternate reality version of peter
even though she knows it's not her
actual nephew she knows it's not that
peter parker from the the ultimate
universe
gives her a chance to effectively say
goodbye right to say her goodbyes and
and you know indirectly
say it to peter parker from ultimate
universe to give her closure it's
basically what this
does something that she's never had this
entire time and so miles morales looking
out the window realizes uh
okay shields on their way we need to go
right because shield is a lot more seedy
in the ultimate universe that they are
in the main marvel universe in the main
marvel universe
they're still kind of jerks but like
they're more inclined to work with you
than against you and the ultimate
universe they're like a like a like a
police force almost right i mean not
specifically but in terms of like how
they function right like they do their
thing
and all there are just people who stand
in the way is basically all that it is
but of course
peter ends up saying goodbye to uh to
everybody here and then of course he
ends up getting in the car with uh nick
fury miles morales and it's kind of a
funny thing because nick fury asks like
is there a nick fury where you come from
and he's like yeah but he's kind of a
white guy and then like nick fury's like
sorry to hear that man
which is kind of a funny thing but again
it gives aunt mae the closure she needs
and that's why when the story came out
it was so huge it was wrapping up all
these plot threads
right all these little things that have
been left hanging and the reality is
that if anybody but brian michael bendis
had taken this over we probably would
have never seen this right but bendis
started off with the ultimate spider-man
he originally created it
it makes sense that he would basically
end it here and kind of continue things
on with miles and that's why
spider-man is so important it's one part
wrapping up plot threads that vendors
never got to wrap
up after the death of peter parker in
the ultimate universe in the cataclysm
story and it was a way to kind of
officially transition into miles and
we'll find more
you'll find out more why that's the case
when we get once we get to the end of
this
but when he when he really meets with
you know tony stark he's kind of like
okay so there's a few differences here
like one
the tony stark in my universe stopped
drinking a while ago which
nick fury loves and two it's obvious
this guy's not as smart and so with with
tony kind of being like look like
i need to know where his home is i need
to know where your universe is
uh when peter starts to point him in
that direction then it turns into okay
then we could
at the very least figure out how to get
you back right we could figure we could
figure out how to reverse engineer this
stuff now make no mistake tony stark's
not doing this out of the goodness of
his heart tony stark's doing this one
part because he was directed by nick
fury but two
because he can get something out of it
right i mean this is a level of
technology that tony just doesn't have
access to being able to attain this
technology and use it for his own ends
it's a huge benefit right it's something
that he desperately wants here and so
once once they're basically looking at
the broadcast
that mysterio has been putting out you
know over the internet you know all day
long and for how many days he's been
here
miles picks up on the fact that one of
these buildings is actually in brooklyn
right he's like one of these buildings
in brooklyn
i'm familiar with it and so they know
exactly where it is mysterio is
operating out of right they know his
base of operations once they locate that
nick fury calls in everyone and when i
say everyone i mean
an entire shield strike team alongside
spider-man and alongside
the ultimate thor what's going on guys
this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with the conclusion of
spider-man yes we are we are wrapping up
the spider-man event
uh and this is probably the single most
important part of the story not
necessarily because of what's happened
so far but because of the future
of miles morales so what we end up doing
here is we initially pick up with
mysterio
and mysterio is suffering from the same
problem that every super villain suffers
from
stupidity so the idea behind this with
mysterio
so the idea behind this with mysterio is
that he comes to the realization
that he actually unintentionally
defeated spider-man that with spider-man
being whisked off into this other
dimension where peter parker in that
reality is dead
that it leaves no spider-man in this
universe right in the main marvel
universe there is no peter parker here
right he's
off in the ultimate universe somewhere
and it was something that mysterio
had not really thought of before and now
he realizes it like man dude okay
like i actually defeated spider-man but
then the question becomes why isn't it
enough
right like why is it not enough he's
like i have to see it right i have to
see him suffer and die i'll just take a
peek for myself just for one moment now
this is brian michael bendis being brian
michael bendis if it were me writing the
story it would be like oh man dude i won
cool
the end and that would be it right it
would be mysterio realizing he basically
got the upper hand on peter parker and
there's no no more spider-man here such
as it is
then just wanted to tell the story and
so so basically mysterio comes to the
realization that he wants to actually
see spider-man suffer and die and so he
reopens he basically reactivates the
portal and takes a peek inside
only for webbing to come flying out
and the big should basically attach
itself to him and then of course you
have peter parker you have miles morales
and the ultimate team who's there right
the ultimate avengers who were all there
and it's kind of like well crap
right like well damn like that's that's
basically it right like okay
i mean who could have possibly seen that
coming the cool thing about this though
is that one thing to understand with
mysterio is he's usually always got an
ace up his sleeve and that's one of the
things that makes him so dangerous
right and so where you have nick fury
you've got the rest of the guys who are
kind of like cool the day
saved keep in mind they're not used to
the kind of villains you have in the
main marvel universe where somehow they
always have some kind of an escape plan
or something like that remember the main
marvel universe is a lot less realistic
than the ultimate universe was and so
mysterio
immediately types away and just starts
releasing a whole host of these
chemicals and sets off an explosion and
when that happens
basically everybody here like iron man
nick fury miles morales all these
various guys are met by what are
essentially their worst nightmares right
it's literally what they're exposed to
using the power
of mysterio he exposes all of them to
their worst nightmares right so you've
got all the ultimates who are dead at
the hands of tony stark which of course
is definitely an allusion to what we saw
in the marvel cinematic universe you've
got nick fury who's watching the world
on fire watching the world burn green
goblin has killed aunt may
in the eye in front of i'm sorry really
dr octopus and green goblin have killed
aunt may in front of spider-man and then
you've got the prowler who killed
miles morales mother and father and so
because of that where everybody else is
kind of succumbing to this
miles sort of succumbs to it a little
bit but then
manages to get the upper hand on it even
if only for a moment and when that
happens he realizes mysterio's making a
break for the portal and he tackles
mysterio now by all standards of
measurement
miles should have should have been 100
incapacitated here and again
that's kind of the critique of bendis
right venice is just well of course
miles morales has to be on top he's the
guy that i'm riding right now he's the
main spider-man we can't have him lose
right so it's kind of like okay you know
it's sort of you just kind of go with it
in this story right it's just kind of
the way that bendis does it but where
you end up having mysterio who of course
uses powers on miles yet again he almost
gets the upper hand
miles dodges the attack goes invisible
and the mysterio trying to figure out
what happens
ends up being attacked by miles again
now again this has kind of been just
basically saying like this is how
capable miles is now the reality of this
is that while this was kind of i
wouldn't say far fetched but kind of
like what in the world's going on here
you know back in the day in this day and
age it's
common practice and it kind of makes
sense i think that with this story and
and miles being able to overcome
mysterio so
fast despite mysterio's abilities was
really more of just bendis wanting to
tell the story as opposed to just kind
of letting it play out organically
in reality having somebody like mysterio
was probably not the best
vet they probably should have been
somebody more like dr octopus because
mysterio's powers are not limited to
just some kind of tentacles attached to
his back that go after you then he
messes with your mind he messes with
your head and so there isn't really a
whole lot of reason to believe that
miles would somehow be able to overcome
this so quickly right if you're trying
to maintain that kind of comic book lore
that we're used to and kind of maintain
consistency
then you know it's something you would
kind of expect but with uh peter parker
able to overcome it as well alongside
miles they take out mysterio
pretty quickly right he's defeated
pretty fast and so from that point what
they end up doing is actually keeping
mysterio
inside the ultimate universe and the
reason why is because mysterio now knows
that peter parker's spider-man and so it
kind of creates this situation where
peter's like
okay cool yeah man hold on to him i
appreciate it guys
thanks for looking out it's kind of the
shady thing to do but
this is really the most important moment
that comes out of this right which is
why we kind of
more or less ham-fisted our way through
this there's a point where peter and
miles are talking and
peter basically thanks him for keeping
the legacy of spider-man going and when
miles asks him like does that mean that
i have your blessing peter's like
absolutely this was brian michael bendis
giving a big middle finger to the
naysayers and we talked about that
before that when miles first showed up
there were a lot of people who were
really pissy about the fact that peter
parker and the ultimate universe had
been killed and they wanted they didn't
want miles they wanted peter parker the
response of bendis is you already have
peter parker
you've had him for like 50 years right
you've had peter parker for a long long
time
you need to get over yourselves right
it's time for a new spider-man it's time
to kind of continue on this story
focusing on somebody else we can't do
that in the main marvel universe because
peter parker is etched in stone
forevermore
the spider-man in the main marvel
universe we can't change that marvel
editorial won't let me change it and
even if i wanted to it'd be a terrible
idea to do it anyway but in the ultimate
universe i created this character then
just giveth bendis take it
and take it away and that's kind of his
that's kind of his stance on that and so
when you had a lot of people who were
giving him flack and really complaining
a lot on the the various form boards and
social media different things like that
about miles morales taking over the role
of spider-man in the ultimate universe
this was really been to saying no he's
not going anywhere right if what you
expected me to do was to basically
give in acquiesce and admit defeat and
say hey you know you
you 50 comic book fans who sound like 5
million obviously you guys don't like
miles morales so let me just get rid of
him and bring back peter parker if
that's what you were expecting then i'm
sorry you're gravely mistaken that's
not what's going to happen and so we
ended up just getting miles more alice
going forward and so it's one of these
things where with with miles kind of
getting the official blessing
of peter parker that you have this
moment where nick fury kind of pulls him
aside and says
you got his blessing man like you earned
it kid right if that spider-man the real
true spider-man gives you his blessing
then you're good right just go forward
and do your superhero thing so it's
really not anymore nick fury kind of
questioning miles anymore kind of
looking at him with a skewed eye or
really the only eye he can look at him
at uh look at him with and just kind of
you know this is one his one good eye
kind of looking at him with a skewed eye
and then just kind of being like
is he really gonna be a good spider-man
at this point you know he kind of goes
forward with a whole new level of
confidence that he didn't really have
before
and that's kind of a cool thing because
what you do is you switch over to peter
parker himself
back home right back in his own
apartment he's like miles morales miles
morales i wonder if we have a miles
morales in the main marvel universe and
then it ends now
of course we know as far as i'm aware
that's not true
in in marvel comics right this story was
told like eight years ago so we know
that's not really true
at the time this was written everybody
wanted to know if it was true or not it
was like the biggest
biggest cliffhanger of like a decade
right like i wonder if it's real i
wonder if they really do have a miles
more house in the main marvel universe
and it's like i wonder what's gonna
happen with that right it's kind of
crazy but it is a cool story let me know
what you guys think down in the comment
section did you guys enjoy spiderman the
very first story
the very first time where peter parker
and miles morales meet one another let
me know what you guys think i'm kind of
curious
what your all stance is but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
me
[Music]
do
you